[Music]
e
for
[Music]
round one action from the London chess
classic the last stop on the grand chest
tour the tournament started off with a
bang as 10 of the best players in the
world came looking to finish off the
season in style world number three
Vladimir konnick took on another former
world champion veline topalov in what
has become a ritual Grudge Match and it
was the Russian who was able to dominate
the game from start to finish to take
the early lead in the event Britain's
Michael Adams had a fine position
against leavon aronian from Armenia but
a sudden blunder in one move sent the
hometown favorite down in Flames Grand
chess tour leader Wesley so took on the
birthday boy and fellow American Naru
Nakamura but an inexplicable mistake in
the opening by Naka gifted the point to
his main rival leaving a very happy
Wesley tied for first coming out the
gate the players have shaken off the
first round Jitters and will now look to
uncor some brilliant moves round two
live from London coming up
next
[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone and welcome to the sights
and sounds of London we're in front of
Westminster ABY one of the most famous
Cathedrals built in the 11th century and
the traditional place of Coronation for
English and later British monarchs well
10 of the great Kings of Chess are here
to compete in the second round of the
London chess classic here on the grand
chest tour for more action let's go down
to the studio with our commentators
Tanya Yasser and
[Music]
Alejandro hello and welcome to round two
of the London chess classic I'm Tanya sa
in the studio with grandmas yasa good
morning Tanya delighted to be with you
good morning in St Louis but it's
afternoon in London right now now yeah
sir we started round one and what what
an explosive start we had we had the
world's best players two inexplicable
blunders by Hikaru Nakamura and Mickey
Adams we also had a very very nice crn
esque win uh what was the highlight
moment for for you in round one Wesley
so I mean he's leading the grand chest
tour and he started with a victory over
his closest rival who could potentially
catch him so everything's going for
Wesley at this moment absolutely and in
fact yeser Wesley so did also start the
sink field cup with a first round win
against Hikaru earlier this year and and
in a funny way in that game as well
Hikaru blitzed out the opening moves and
made a blunder really soon only to go
down very quickly to so and he went on
to win the tournament will he live the
dream again we're going to find out
let's take a look at the current
standings VES so Vladimir and leevon
aronian all three had big wins yesterday
a great way to start the London chess
classic are on one point mvl Anish G
Fabiano and vishy Drew their games
Hikaru Nakamura vaselin too and Micky
Adams the Wild Card entry not a great
start but definitely the tournament has
just begun so they're going to be
looking at bouncing back they're at the
bottom of the board let's also take a
look at the classic format it's a 10
player round robin event 40 moves in two
hours and the remainder of the game in
60 minutes what's interesting is that
the 30 second increment that all of us
are so used to only begins from move 41
and this was quite a key factor in the
game Karana against bishy yesterday
because Karana did have some chances but
in the first time control scramble he
did give those away exactly uh forc to
move under the pressure of the clock
came Miss some key opportunities late in
that game right let's also take a look
at our field of players in the world
rankings Fabiano Carana Vladimir Kik and
Maxim Bashir lra world number two three
and four all
2800s a very important point that 11
players are in the history of Chess only
11 players have crossed the 2800 Mark
yaser and out of those 118 are here in
the field in London chess classic it's
extraordinary and look at Wesley so he's
just just on the outside looking in he'd
love to make it a dozen and to cross
that barrier himself what an incredible
year W has had jump to world number five
and Us number two overtaking Hikaru
Nakamura so it's quite a field and
despite not having the world champion
Magnus Carlson it is the strongest
London chess classic absolutely we also
have with us grandm Alejandra Ramirez
with his insides thank you Tanya and you
said it yourself what an explosive way
to start the London classic three
decisive games and today I want to
follow the leaders and see how they
match up in today's games we have the
game between Vladimir karnick and leevon
Ronan a very classic match up between
two strong veterans you can see that
karnick has been favored traditionally
in this match up but many many draws
this is one of those positional
struggles that I'm really excited about
it's the clash between the classicist
here in the London chess classic and of
course we have to keep an eye on Wesley
saw the grand chest tour leader he's
white against Micky Adas who did not
show good form yesterday Micky started
playing very well but a blunder is all
it takes to erase anything that you've
done previously in the game and that's
what happened in his game against
aronian now the only question is how
does Wesley not win the tournament and
the only way is for hikaro Nakamura to
win the London chess classic outright he
cannot have a playoff and at the same
time for wesle so to finish fourth or
more lower in the tournament that is the
only way that hikaro Nakamura can win
the event and that's the only way that
Wesley doesn't take the entire Grand
chess tour with us live from London is
Grandmaster Maurice
Ashley well the city is a buzz at least
the chess fans are anyway having the
London chess classic here and it's the
weekend so everyone is attending you
have a feed open going on you have the
British knockout Championship first
place there is is 20,000 lb lots of kids
and people were not worried about taking
a day off because again it's Saturday so
the place is packed the fans are all
here of course the players will want to
bring their aame today given the
blunders that we saw yesterday
definitely round two is going to be a
very tense round very exciting and we
will be calling the action live from
London bringing you updates back to you
in the studio thank you Maurice and
again in London it's a real Festival
isn't it what's going on over here of
Chess I mean the feed open itself is so
strong they've got players like Laura
fres you've got elot Safari uh Benjamin
Bach a lot of top Grand Masters playing
there then you've also got the British
Knockouts uh it and like Maurice said
the weekends it's all about Chess there
wow how exciting very nice well let's
take a look at the schedule for the
London chess
classic we're going into round two it
begins at 8:00 a.m. Central Time on
weekdays it is at at 10:00 a.m. Central
Time Wednesday December 14th is a rest
day for players and we start at 8:00
a.m. today absolutely and we're getting
ready for the opening of round two and
I'm just thinking about Wesley's
situation I mean it's almost like he's
living a fantasy uh a year ago at the
SFI cup he was last place last place yes
he wins first and here he is uh had
Magnus Carlson played in the tournament
played in the whole cycle I mean uh
Wesley wouldn't have been invited he
would have been the reserve player so
imagine you know like just opening up
that window of opportunity and look how
he's a when it goes right then
everything goes right and it's it's
interesting because at the start of the
singfield cup there was this whole
feature that we did where we asked the
players who they thought would win the
singfield cup and nobody named Wesley
right he went on to convincingly win the
sinkfield cup and here he is looking
almost Unstoppable for the second
addition of the grand chest store none
of the players but uh by the way I
predicted his victory wow and you look
at the tape you have to look at the tape
and there we see some of the play
players walking into the Kensington
Olympia playing Hall it is an absolutely
stunning Hall where you can see the
spectators have a direct undisturbed
view of the players the players take
their position on the stage and there is
absolutely no division between the
spectators and the players if you find
yourself in London definitely drop in by
the Kensington Olympia now there's a lot
of Side Stories going on besides just
the grand chest tour and we see Malcolm
Payne about to introduce the players one
of them is Fabiana Karana at number two
in the world if he could put together an
extraordinary result such as plus4 in
this event he could potentially overtake
Magnus Carlson on the number one ranking
that would be absolutely historical it
been years since Magnus hasn't been
number one like we said he needs to pull
a car
yes he does another interesting story is
Vladimir karnick himself he's number
three in the world and he with thanks to
his victory he's edging up and he's
saying look everybody I may have been a
former world champion but I'm still a
force to be reckoned with I think that's
absolutely incredible I mean cnick is
definitely one of the more senior
players in the Chess World today and to
be at world number three with an over
2800 rating and yesterday he showed such
class winning that game against vessel
in a trademark cnick style I mean he is
definitely a force to reckon with and
you cannot even put it past him that he
could be one of our future world
champion Challengers again oh absolutely
and here we were in the smackdown uh in
St Louis just uh a few weeks ago and
when you see vintage v vishy ah let's go
to London and Malcolm as he introduces
the players on
stage the chief
of Chess in schools and communities
which stages the London chess classic uh
London chess classic is all about
supporting the charity which delivers
chess to State primary schools all over
the UK uh right now the charity is
working in over 600 schools either
delivering chess lessons or chess sets
uh as well as providing tournaments and
all the educational materials uh
required to bring chess to State schools
uh I'm delighted to say that we've had
lots of support from people in the
audience and all around the world who
are donating to the charity you can do
that via the links on the live web pages
uh anywh you like uh PayPal facts uh
we'll probably even work out a way for
you to do it uh by just closing your
eyes but uh for the moment use the
conventional methods you can also learn
more about the charity if you visit the
stand in the uh foyer uh one of my
colleagues is there with lots of
information from the charity if you'd
like your school to start playing chess
if it currently doesn't if your children
attend a school that doesn't play chess
then of course uh we'd love to get chess
started in your school for you and we've
got uh everything that's required to get
you going so go and see one of my
colleagues in the play and we'll get
that sorted out now the London chest
classic is delighted to be the fourth
and final leg of the grand CH tour uh
we've had three tournaments so far in
Paris and St Louis and there's a race on
for
$150,000 in bonus prize money uh we can
have a look uh at the standings at some
point and
um I
think that the battle was uh well to an
extent decided yesterday but I think
actually there's still everything to
play for I think the lead of res so will
come under some pressure from all his
Rivals here for the top prize there's
also a second prize of $50,000 and that
means that in total there is
$450,000 of prize money at stake at the
London chess
classic I'd like now to welcome the
players onto the stage so on the center
stage a man who won the World Chess
Championship here in 2000 just down the
road in hammeri defeating Gary
kaspero we're always honored to have him
here he always entertains us you please
welcome from Russia Vladimir
[Applause]
KY and this is a game between two
players you know this is a recurring
theme in this tournament the players
need to have pens I don't know who was
in yesterday changing you know you don't
two people put on their
P this is a battle between two players
who both W their yest today so please
welcome from aronian excuse me from
Armenia
[Applause]
leonian
no got a new opportunity here I think we
need to get we need get
T they've all been checked these pens
got and no transmitters no no okay so
all my left please
welcome the grand chess tour current
leader from the United States Wesley
so and cl Wesley please a war welcome
for the wild card at the London chess
classic the England number one Michael
Adams
on this
board please welcome another former
world champion from India
mishigan I'm playing fishy today the
French number one Maxi Vash
l
[Applause]
on my right playing white from Bulgaria
former world champion veline
too and playing bessing the world's
second ranked player Fabiano Caro from
the
USA
from Holland please welcome Anish
[Applause]
giring I'm playing Anish from the USA
Hikaru
Nakamura those of you who never been it
before or never watched online before
may not know that is a longstanding
tradition of the L chest classic but in
keeping with our association with a
chess in school's charity we like to
have some young players to make the
ceremonial first moves we're going to
have two today and first up from harro
chess club one of their most promising
Juniors who attends Canon Lane primary
school please welcome Mel
[Applause]
pesi right me you've got to make a move
for a for world champion so make sure
it's a really good move okay what would
you like to
play Oh
E4 pretty good Mo V uh yes I would also
like to play it but I will
not great yes I those of you who in any
doubt the grand Masters don't have to
keep the move and there is a there is a
great video on YouTube where somebody
played W KN H3 I don't I don't know who
was the victim in that case but they
look momentarily concerned
thank you very much if you go back and
take your
seat now to another very strong Junior
player I can see sitting with former
sitting with Jonathan Hawkins Hawkins
wow he's got some good backup would you
please welcome S
laer I asked who his CH he was and he
said it was fish so I thought let him
make the first move for
M now so what would you what would you
like to
play4 is popular today would you like to
make that move on the board then for
mRNA very good Shake mr's hand that's it
brilliant fantastic
well what's your assessment of the
situation I probably keep it probably
probably going to keep it there are that
doesn't happen too
often okay Round of Applause please
to
[Applause]
so round two kicking off in the typical
London chess very endearing very
endearing with the children let's take a
look at the matchups for today Vladimir
Kik versus leavon aronian a great
classical match I mean both players
yaser are such strategic solid players
if anybody's looking to improve their
games you just study you just study the
two of them I mean you might not see
fireworks on the board but amazing
amazing strategy then we've got vesselin
versus Fabiano caruana world number two
now again this is an important game
because Fabiano is black withit he's
probably going to be looking at a result
today seeing that veselin is probably
still slightly out of form from
yesterday he's in a wobble yeah yes and
then we've got former world champion
vishy Anand against the French Maestro
mvl Anish giri is up against Hikaru
Nakamura after yesterday's disastrous
blunder on move 13 not the ideal way to
celebrate ones birthday Hikaru I'm sure
is going to come back and fight back in
today's round then we've got Wesley so
our big leader of the grand chest store
up against Mickey Adams who really truly
the Wild Card entry of the London ja
classic who truly played a really good
game yesterday with at the very last
minute London absolutely that's that's
what happened indeed and the money yes
let's take a look at the big p so
$300,000 is the prize fund for the
London chess classic first goes home
with 75 $5,000 second 50,000 and the
bonus pool of the grand Chester priz
fund the player to run away with the
first place in the grand Chester this
year goes back with $100,000 and second
with 50,000 so a total of
$450,000 at state in the London chess
classic will be decided in London
absolutely yes an amazing way to end the
year and of course it's it's a very
crucial tournament because all these
players are looking to end 2016 on a
high note absolutely that's what they're
here for and what a galaxy of stars I
must say just as the players were being
introduced I was just thinking to myself
just how great these players are it's
truly an extraordinarily Elite field you
mentioned so many
2800s we have the we have eight of the
world's top 10 here yes that's big and
uh we know in the history of Chess that
11 players have made it to the 2800 club
and how many of them are eight of them
are here
of the 11 yes and Wesley so trying to
become the 12th and he's opened up with
D4 and uh now the question is are we
going to see in nzo by the way I I just
loved that uh with um
uh pardon me Vladimir so the young young
lady makes the move E4 and he goes I
would like to play that move and I know
exactly what he means you know I'm going
I'm not going to but I'd like to because
we all know that e for is the best but
the theory that you need to know to play
it so well yes oh you got to work too
hard and let's just go over to Alejandro
for a moment oh not yet he's not he's
just getting his board set up but also I
think it's I mean Vladimir is such a
classical player you know I mean uh it
just generally people who do open with
E4 there is like you said so much Theory
so much so many possibilities that lead
to certain positions that might not be
his style of play exactly and I think
that goes along long way in determining
what opening choices you have as a
player what kind of positions you like
to play yes yes indeed and we're just
having a little transmission error on
our side otherwise we'd be jumping right
into the game I just see that uh
Vladimir has opened up with his
standard3 G3 the Strategic opening
choice I have to say yasa that we see
this kind of an opening and this sort of
a set up a lot at the top level I think
one big reason for that is that it's
just a game open into so many positional
ideas and Concepts and not completely
theoretical exactly well a lot of the
very forcing lines whether it be the
grun felds or bonis or Kings Indians
these really forcing lines the sharp
stuff ends up in many cases being drawn
without play absolutely and this
approach by Vladimir which he's adopted
exactly you get a game and dnik and
aronian have played plenty of times yes
they've had 26 draws thetime score is 7
to3 to kramnick and what is amazing is
despite the high number of draws between
them it's deceiving because their games
are always extremely long fought exactly
yes I mean there could have been a lot
more decisive games because both of them
go to the full measure right that's
definitely going to be a big strategic
fight that we're looking forward to the
other big match I think for today is
going to be the on and mvl matchup okay
and we did see E4 by vishy yes we did
which he made pretty clear when the
little kid walked up and played E4 that
he was going to go for it keep he's
going to keep it and I obviously Mr
nidorf uh we mvl as his moniker is known
he loves the nidorf defense and um we
are about to find out if they played it
or not again we're just having some
transmission problems get into that game
shortly let's see it does look like a
open didn't it uh Missing C pwn open
Sicilian right uh well we're going to
find out what I think was also it is in
fact a night off we have on the board
and what I think was really interesting
about yesterday was what Anish said the
fact that he decided to employ the night
off against a night off specialist mvel
yes I mean if you ever play the night
off the one players game that you have
to really study is Maxim yes and in my
day it was Gary Kasparov he loved the
nidor and the generation before it was
Bobby fiser yes so a lot of nidorf
Defense lovers over the years I remember
when I so when I started playing I was
playing the E4 very often and uh against
the night off because I was such a Bobby
Fisher fan I used to often employ the
soen which oh no with Bish C4 and that's
rotten the Soviet should never have been
allowed to name that opening the
San played it like three times lost
twice Bobby Fisher played it a of course
the Fisher the Fisher uh line um in the
San we'll get to that once we get our
boards up and running for the moment
we're just going to stay with the London
webcam views and Maxim Vis MBL he had a
breakthrough year remember a year ago in
London where he lost oh a a
heartbreaking tiebreaker after like 8 n
hours of play and was was almost out of
the uh Grand chest tour at that moment
it was really uh quite a quite a shock
now he's in very very comfortably in the
world's top players and and he's proved
that he belongs exactly there and this
is their uh this is their score against
each other so they've actually vishy and
mvl haven't played that much together
which is surprising yeah because these
are such great players only three
decisive games three decis seven games
in all three decisive games vishy leads
with two to1 and now that we do have our
moves on our board let's get caught up
with our key matchup game between our
two leaders Vladimir karnick and leavon
Rooney and let's take it from the top we
had Knight F3 D5 G3 Knight F6 Bishop G2
kingside Fe and cetto uh by Vladimir
castles I always called this uh
variation building a fortress you know
like I lost so many games when I was
starting I I discovered how difficult it
is to Checkmate white I'd lose inve 30
but at least I didn't get checkmated in
five the great the funny thing about
this variation is that you often look at
it that do you want to play it with
white or how would you react to it with
black and the thing is every time you
sit down to prepare it with white I
constantly feel like I struggle to find
the advantage but when I'm playing with
black I struggle to find how am I going
to equalize exactly it's one of those
one of those openings truly and we all
know that experience now here we are in
a position where Vladimir kramnick has
played the Catalan basically as a
career-long weapon D2 D4 transposes into
the main lines of the catalon B2 B3
basically saying I think you're really
well prepared for my Catalan I'm going
to slow play it for a moment with B3 B6
so lot of fianchetto occurring in this
game let me just take that last move
back Knight C3 does provoke D4 but there
a problem this bishop on G2 is in Ambush
and I think everybody could get this far
but sometimes when you do take that Rook
you want to make sure that the bishop
gets out I'm pretty sure it does this is
just too much material for white it's
going to have Black's going to have a
hard time capturing that Bishop so there
was no D4 opportunity so Bishop B7 D4
and we're up to dat with the play so
these two players are playing it uh
slope playing it I'm going to send it
over to Alejandro and tell us what you
know about this uh position on
Leandra well y this is actually one of
my favorite openings with white so you
know very boring positional style it
suits me quite well D4 is actually a
very unusual move the uh most of the
times you try to play E3 and then simply
play Queen E2 Rook D1 kik's actually the
one that made this into a relatively
popular po idea and it's something
that's picked up steam in the last few
years um many top players have actually
been employing it I've seen gear use it
he used it against a non candidates a
lot of important games have been played
in this variation now with the specific
move order I don't remember seeing the
move d4 specifically but it makes a lot
of sense here because it puts the
pressure on black to define the center
and this is what this game's about
defining the central structure black
would love to play the move C5 at some
point just breaking everything open
however it has to be done in a very
specific way for example if you do it
here and I take on C5 now you still have
to calculate if you ever take with this
pawn and I take on D5 you're going to be
saddled with the isolated Pawns in the
center also called The Hanging pawns
because they cannot be defended by any
pawns on the sides which is a permanent
weakness on the other hand it does give
you a lot of space on the center so it
could be worth considering you could
also calculate after uh C5 D takes C5
what happens if I take on C4 but does
this allow me to to equalize immediately
I have to go into some thought for this
to actually work do I take first can he
take on C4 immediately or how about this
can I take with the bishop now I have to
calculate what if the Knight moves and
he keeps attacking the pawn can I play
Knight E5 and attack on D5 or maybe even
the subtle Knight E1 rerouting to D3 and
attacking on D5 notice that D4 allows C5
immediately which is a very rich type of
idea there's a lot of calculation to be
done immediately even though it seems
like this should be a theoretical
position I know that D4 hasn't been used
very often and this is why aonian is
thinking right now because the
simplification or the definition of the
center is a very important decision in
this structure if you do it wrong
karnick will obtain one of his very nice
slow but subtle advantages that he loves
converting so aronia wants to equalize
as cleanly as possible and sometimes
it's not so clear how to do it he wants
to make sure that whatever break he does
is well timed he might not he might
choose not to do it immediately and just
play n 7 develop a little bit for now as
we see him thinking about his choices he
knows that cring has looked specifically
at this variation with D4 first so he
has to make sure that the C5 break which
he has to do at some point comes at the
right timing he's trying to see if it's
good to do it now or do it a little bit
later now I'm also very interested in
this game between vishy Anan and Maxim
vasher gra because hey it's a nidorf
right nidor are always interesting but
what really strikes me is that we were
talking about this move H3 as pretty
much the flagship idea in the narf right
now everybody's playing H3 it's the
fashionable thing to do Bishop E3 and
Bishop G5 which were the sharp force
variations have given quite a bit of
ground to this idea of H3 a very
positional approach that has a lot of
poison to it now the interesting thing
here is that after E5 almost always the
Knight retreats to E2 and we've seen
vishy over and over Retreat the Knight
to E2 and play a very quick Knight D5 he
used this against toala earlier in year
and the candidates with an excellent
result but here he's playing the move
Knight B3 which is not the usual idea
when you play the H3 variation he has a
very specific point and this is
something that grandelius used against
giri in the Qatar open of 2015 I had the
pleasure of annotating this game and
actually analyzing it with giri after he
finished and it was a very sharp
positional struggle after Bishop B6 the
point is that you very quickly go F4 and
on KN bd7 you keep going G4 so this is
the T type of games that uh we have
nowadays in the night ORF white is
simply throwing his pawns forward on the
king side saying hey your piece is here
even though they're welld developed
they're not very well posted if I just
Advance my pawns here for example the
move G5 is already quite an unpleasant
threat as the Knight doesn't have any
good squares to go to here if you're not
very well prepared in this line it's
just something that's unpleasant to have
to decide during the game how do I make
some room for the knight uh the computer
is suggesting to move Rook C8 in order
to just completely ignore the move G5 as
you have the idea of taking on C3 a very
classical Sicilian counter sacrifice
with the idea that if you take my Rook
I'm going to have the ability to destroy
your Pawn Center not only does Rook C8
allow this idea of taking on C3 it also
allows me that if you ever push F5 now
I'm not entirely forced to take on B3
even though at this point I might want
to I can also consider going Bishop C4
at some point so Rook C8 is the
preferred move move of the engine and I
see that Maxim has just splited some
very fascinating struggles in the
opening already as the players are
trying to surprise their opponents and I
like the preparation that we see from
the white side right good start for
round two so theoretical yaser that a
slight inaccuracy in the opening just
doesn't mean that you have a strategic
problem it just basically means that
you're lost you've got to be so well
prepared in the night off exactly and
the lines are so deep and lengthy to
actually be able to play it as an expert
I don't see why Vladimir doesn't stop
with E4 yes you understand and the uh in
our other tournament leaders game Wesley
so we actually have a straight up proper
Catalan U Mickey Adams um with black
against Wesley so and for Mickey Mickey
is really a systems man he just plays
his openings extremely well he knows
them on the inside as and outside and
this is a position that he's always
played as black the so-called open line
of the Catalan and he's got a lot of
experience with it with this crafty
little move A6 A5 you might think to
yourself that black uh was only thinking
about a B7 B5 move no this move A6 A5
after the move A2 A4 has been played
essentially Mickey is saying I'm going
to plant my night on the B4 Square okay
it's not centralized but it'll have a
very powerful influence in Middle game
no if you've got to play A5 you have to
play it before you develop that Knight
on D7 exactly that's another way to play
but if you've got to go for A5 you get
that Knight on B4 exactly and so we see
that game there and let me just go
around the horn a little
bit okay and this is the game between
Anish giri and Hikaru Nakamura again uh
more of a Catalan type of position but
this time we could have almost
transposed into a king's Indian now this
was actually a very uh key moment for
Anish giri after this move C5 basically
this move is a challenge it's saying do
you want to play the move d4 D5 and
permit a bonon as well as potentially a
Beno the Bon would have gone for example
E6 let's go Knight C3 3 oops I'm going
to get my knight to C3 takes on D5 takes
on D5
D6 and I remember a game between um
Victor KY and Gary Kasparov at an
Olympiad in lot CERN which just had the
whole uh audience transfixed I mean it
was up on a big screen and I remember
the entire American team watching this
and this is a very very sharp uh
variation and it was a great game uh
Onish Gary declined that challenge and
instead after the move C5 played Knight
C3 and recaptured with the queen this of
course also is very well-known strategy
uh White intends to meet the move Knight
C6 by bringing his Queen over to the
king side as a
preparate preparatory move to the move
Bishop H6 getting rid of that Fortress
Bishop on G7 because in such structures
in general you should aim at exchanging
the dark Squad B because it's a not it's
not just eyeing this long diagonal but
it's also a very important Defender for
Black's King key defender of Black's
King and we'll turn it over to Alejandro
Alejandro well guys while you were
discussing this game I just had to look
because I play the English quite a lot
and I thought that you take on D4 almost
automatically with the Knight yes um I
do not recall taking with the queen on
this specific variation even though it's
a common idea and I was looking at it
with the database the database tells me
Knight F3 takes D4 has been played in
1,228 master level or above games and
queen takes D4 has been played in
27 quite a difference Anisha has played
Queen takes D4 very quickly and you can
see that he car is thinking because I
really don't know the plan here after
Queen takes D4 um it's very specific to
the position the idea as you mentioned
of a very quick Queen H4 Bishop H6 is
dangerous but for some reason it just
has not really been employed at any
point everybody almost takes on uh D4
with the Knight
immediately it and while we are looking
at these games I will say that we have a
lot of action in some other ones but we
will first go to Maurice in
London yes and there you have you guys
are looking at some boring englishes and
and here in in London we have live
commentary by uh Chris Ward and Lauren
shren it looking at some boring frenches
and I'm going to tell you you just want
to pay attention to the night ORF that's
all that's going on right now as Anan is
going Hog Wild against mexim Vash lrav
he's played the move F5 the pawn
steaming down the board and the move
Bishop takes B3 Alejandro mentioned the
possibility of Bishop to C4 here but he
is taken and taken back and now this
position is quite fascinating because
there's an exchange sacrifice on the
board that Maxim Vash lrav is
considering he has not yet played this
move Rook takes C3 takes and then Knight
takes on e4 and the position is simply
exploded he's threatening of course
Queen chck with some nasty mating ideas
Anna's going to have to respond to this
the engine is giving only H4 as a real
good move here but look at this Pawn
formation what is happening it's chaos
in this game a fascinating night or of
foot will keep you up to date as the
game continues wow thank you
Maurice yeah Rook C3 is such a typical
night off sacrifice which you always
white have to yes a sicilian sacrifice
which you always have to be so careful
about absolutely scary but wish the way
he's playing he's blitzed out his moves
I'm sure he's he's very very very well
prepared but I'm looking at that Queen
H4 check and I'm going whoa that's a
really scary uh threat we had an
incredibly uh shocking move for my eyes
between uh Wesley and Mickey Adams
Mickey Adams played a
move I can't remember playing that
except during my beginner days maybe you
did the same thing wanting to get your
cannons into the game we just saw this
move A7 A5 A6 A5 pardon me which was
clearly telegraphing the desirous Knight
A6 B4 maneuver and he played Rook A6 but
you know yasa it is quite an interesting
move I mean I've seen it somewhere it's
the whole idea is yes to go Rook B6 the
Knight will come to B4 at some point but
first he just transfers The Rook to B6
it's a it's a very it's a great way to
actually develop The Rook cuz otherwise
it's just on8 you attack the B2 Pawn
you're you're threatening Rook B4 at
times the Knight will decide whether it
wants to come out on D7 or A6 depends on
the position but it's quite an
interesting way to play not the main way
to play not the main move in the
position but still a very a very
interesting idea well you haven't
convinced me I hopefully Mick will
hopefully Mickey will but Rook A6 it
looks really absurd to me I'd probably
play E3 and after Rook B6 i' just
probably drop back with my queen and
they say okay well done uh youve got
your Rook on B6 but I mean isn't it a
potential Target I can in the future
play Knight E5 C4 very controversial to
my eyes uh Alejandro what say
ye well yaser you gotta get updated
man latest and greatest Rook A6 is the
cool way to play nowadays I mean Knight
A6 is the old main line here with Knight
A6 and going to B4 but Rook A6 has
really caught the attention of most of
the Catalan players with the black side
and hey if Leon Ronin has played it
three times in classical chess it's got
to be a good move good point I didn't
realize that leavon had played it three
times indeed he played it against giri
against Nakamura and I'm failing to see
the other one but I know he played it
three times he drew both games so so far
so good E3 is the mainline but Wesley
has very quickly played the moves Queen
D3 Rook B6 Queen to C2 and I've seen
this idea of put pushing the Rook all
the way to B6 the idea being that even
though the Rook looks kind of awkward
it's actually very annoyingly placed on
B4 because once it gets there you would
like to kick it out but it's not so
clear how you do so you never really
want to play B3 and weaken your queen
side a little bit if you play Knight A2
this Pawn on A4 is always hanging the
pawn on D4 is hanging so you have to
play E3 at some point if you Retreat the
Knight this allows me to trade Bishops
which is something that you don't really
want to allow so even though the Rook on
B4 looks kind of weird it's very
difficult to actually kick it out of
this Square now it doesn't mean that the
Rook has to go there immediately of
course you can still play Knight A6 or
Knight bd7 first Wesley surely has
something up his sleeve because he's
playing very quickly but this idea of
Rook A6 Rook B6 has definitely become
the standard of how to play the this
line of the open catalon wow shame on me
that I'm not up to date on my latest and
greatest and talking about not being up
to date on my latest and greatest in
opening Theory I'm looking at the game
between vesselin topof and Fabiana
Karana now I love to play the French uh
in my youth uh I enjoyed the
counterattacking possibilities of blacks
position white seizes the center in uh
the French as we see here this Pawn
chain extending from B2 all the way to
E5 and I really want to Target this Pawn
as black on D4 and so I'd always want to
play the move Knight the maneuver either
Knight G8 to H6 to F5 or Knight E7 F5
and almost never nobody would ever play
the move H2 H4 against me because of
course I would play H5 and I'd firmly
establish my knight on F5 but here we
have a very early move seven H4 by
vesselin and I know Alejandra is about
to tell me oh yes this has been seen in
the the elite grandm games I have to say
yes that veselin actually of late has
been playing a lot of openings which
might not be the main line but offer him
creative and aggressive chances in the
on the board and in that particular game
and in that way it is very velent to go
H4 oh I know aleandro update us what is
what's the theory here well I think
toala is trying to surprise his young
opponent because talo played H4 once
already against nikolich in
1997 I think Fabiano was just learning
how the pieces moved back in that year
but that's was when topalo was one of
thep top players in the world already
and he played the move H4 decimated his
opponent in a pretty fine style in this
position the normal moves are either
castles or Knight A3 very standard
French position uh but H4 very
aggressive sorry we have the move H4
here in this position and we have a
couple of games toal played it against
nikich pogar played it against nikolich
uh moan played it against nikich for
nicoles is facing H4 but besides that
there's not that many games it's a very
very rare move very aggressive it has
the clear intentions of gaining space on
the king side which makes a lot of sense
considering the structure
however uh the key question here
strategically is does black want to play
H5 H5 will secure F5 for this Knight
because there will be no G4 no that the
bishop already went to E2 so it will
have to spend another Temple to go to D3
and capture it if it wants but on the
other hand it wickens G5 severely for
White's Knight to go into that position
so is H5 desirable that's not so clear
most people decide not to do that and
instead we see the more common variation
being taking on D4 taking on D4 and then
simply developing the queen to B6 and
saying hey I'm just going to play my
standard French ideas what do you got so
toala has played this before it's just
been almost 20 years well it might be
rare as but I have to say I look at H4
and I feel it is very vesselin to make
that move it is it's a it's a hyper
aggressive move because it's one of
those moves as uh Leandra was pointing
out after H4 H5 white gets the G5 square
if it works out it could work out
brilliantly but if it doesn't work out
You' spent a Tempo potentially simply
weakening yourself on the king side
right also veselin has gone on to say
plenty of times in the recent past that
how he doesn't take chess too seriously
anymore and he's always looking for
creativity and Beauty on the board and
such openings offer that in plenty
especially when you go with a move like
H4 so this is this is their personal
record so we've got they've played quite
a few times 15 times in all and one to
five to Fabiano Carana so he leads
massively and what's also the fun part
is that out of the six decisive results
five are with the black pieces wow
that's uh quite surprising but we have
more recent London
yes yes this position is absolutely
exploded now we're talking about this
nidorf we talked about the sacrifice
Rook takes on C3 in this position which
looked like an interesting move but
another sacrific instead occurred the
move D5 sacrificing the D Pawn to
release his Bishop into the game Anan
took and after Bishop to B4 I was busy
trying to figure out what the variations
were the engine was talking about Bishop
D2 which looks like the most natural
move Anan instantly showing his D
preparation played the move Bishop to G2
here absolutely no hesitation so while
it is that it is NBL the night or
specialist who's having to think and go
deeply into these lines and try to
figure out what how he's going to
sidestep anan's preparation it is Anan
who is cool calm collected in this
moment saying I've got this prep
completely under control yes there's a
rook sacrifice in the position takes
takes but the simple Bishop to D2 and
then when you take just take back and
white has the two Bishops and a massive
Pawn structure against the two knights
wh's King though may be in a little bit
of trouble but the speed in which Anan
is playing makes you think that he's got
this all worked out so we'll see how
this game continues as uh round two goes
on from London thank you m wow no Wishy
is one of his biggest for days
definitely his preparation indeed also
what's really interesting is that vishy
and Maxim haven't played that much often
I mean we've only got seven games but
out of which Yas five have been decisive
wow so and in all formats I mean that's
that's quite so and this looks like it's
heading there as well
uh five have been decis in all different
formats the last five games that
including Rapid Blitz and classical the
last five times right the last five
times that they've met each other we've
had fireworks on the board and with an
opening like that and the way which
she's blitzing out his
preparation I think this is heading that
that way as well absolutely well let me
bring that uh game up on my board
because I promised our viewers that uh
what had happened basically after World
War II the Soviets really really
embraced chess and they really wanted to
put their stamp on it and they put their
names of their players on basically
everything you know they became the
binic variation became the SML variation
you saw all these Russian names and the
nidorf uh key position the tabia of the
nidorf was after A7 A6 and there's a lot
of moves here of course and very very
heavy theoretical moves with Bishop
G5 uh the there's moves like uh Bishop
E3 and this was Bobby Fischer's move
Bishop C4 and that was a secret weapon
and the Soviets seized on this even
wrote a book on this uh on this move
which and I think it was brilliant and I
had a very very good score I mean of
course like this was about 10 years ago
so theories evolved massively and it's
not employed so much anymore but it's
not one of the main moves but yeah it
was I thought it was a great opening
absolutely and Bobby made it one of his
lifetime weapons against the n off which
he played as black and this idiot San he
plays like three games and the Soviets
slap his name on it well the guy loses
two of the three games and draws one and
they they they uh memorialize him with
this legendary San variation and really
the Bobby Fisher yeah I'm understand
San's mom is on the phone so I'll tone
it down but yes okay that didn't happen
H2 H3 has has become very topical and
I'm going to ask Alejandro on this one
because it was really a funky move right
here F5 Bishop takes Pawn takes this
move Rook takes C3 Alejandro dangerous
goodness that would have really
frightened me uh black gets a pawn for
his exchange but this massive threat of
Queen H5 and you've just blown White
Center to
smithin how did the computer evaluate
this position H4 you were saying only
move by white thereafter could you just
take us few
uh for a few moves please well H4 is
absolutely forced I mean you do you
cannot allow this queen to go into this
square and the king would just be too
weak I think the main problem is the
strategical factors at the end of the
day for for black are not as good as the
usual sacrifice let's take a look
compared to the sacrifice that we talked
about earlier notice that White's Pawn
structure here is not exactly shattered
it's actually quite solid you're going
to play C4 at some point notice that
white has the pair of Bishops which in
the long term is going to be very
dangerous for black and specifically he
still has the light squared bishop and
black doesn't which means that all of
his light squares are very weak if black
was able to play a D5 very soon I think
that black would have full compensation
maybe even more because you get a bishop
on C5 you get a queen on B6 you start
really pressuring White's position but
you're not going to be able to do that
D5 is under white control The Bishop's
coming to G2 The Bishop's coming to E3
very fast I don't even care about the C3
Pawn in many scenarios and now you
cannot even take it right now because
after Queen F3 the Knight doesn't have
any good place to go to I'm attacking
the pawn on B7 white is the one that
takes over the initiative it's not about
the material anymore really it's about
who gets the initiative and although
optically it
looks like in this position white is in
some danger because the king seems a
little Airy uh this Pawn on H4 might be
attacked the Knight seems very strong
it's just the fact that black is
underdeveloped he doesn't have the sit
the situational pieces for him to really
EXP exploit the initiative provided by
this N4 by the sacrifice of the exchange
and by the opening of the center in
essence since you're not going to be
able to develop an initiative the parab
Bishops will eventually take over the
computers do like white it's not by a
very big margin but they do like white
for example of the variation Bishop
Bishop B7 I have to defend this Pawn G5
or F6 but that's that's a computer move
like complete computer move which I
wouldn't be surprised and not Blitz us
out because wellar oparation but okay
the computers do prefer the move G5 and
the idea is that after Queen B6
attacking uh position here on F2 Queen
F3 White's simply taking over D5 is now
forced you start playing Bishop B2
you're going to play at some point long
castle and your king is actually
relatively safe on B1 whereas black you
know it doesn't have that many squares
you like to bring the Rook into the game
but you can see how short Castle might
run into some severe problems as I
already have an expansion here of Pawns
which will pretty much Target the king
so it's not so clear Rook takes C3 was
the engine recommendation but it's not
as appealing as a normal Rook take C3
sacrifice in many ways so instead of
that Maxim decided to blast open the
center with D5 and the problem is that
you might be thinking why is anybody
looking at sacrifice materials equal
just develop your pieces it's not so
simple after for example the caress move
Bishop B7 and I simply play G5 Block's
position is already falling apart the
Knight has to retreat that means that
I'm going to get H4 in I have a huge
expansion on the king side the Knight
comes to D5 I have huge control over the
light squares and this is almost
strategically lost so you can't you
don't have the choice of just developing
your pieces D5 seems like a decent
attempt the idea of course being that
after e takes D5 now the bishop comes
into play and the Knight cannot go
itself to D5 I still have to worry about
G5 and Knight E4 so Bishop B4 is kind of
forced Bishop G2 played very quickly
Anan Maxim played a move that is not
considered by the computer which is the
reason why Anan is thinking now because
he's surely out of preparation finally
Queen B6 the idea being that I cannot
short Castle so the king is stuck in the
center on the other hand after the move
Bishop D2 white starts to consolidate if
I play the bishop to D2 and then I play
my queen to E2 and even long Castle
black is the one that has to prove where
is my initiative I'm down a pawn white
has the pair of Bishops yes the king is
not completely happy about the fact that
there are some structural weakness on
the queen side but at the end of the day
a pawn is a pawn and you have the pair
of Bishops
and if you trade a couple of pieces
White's very easily going to take over
the game computers like white vish's
preparation seems to have been working
out he does have to play Bishop D2 the
computers don't see any choice and I see
yet he's reaching for the bishop and
going Bishop D2 it seems like uh he's
paying off very well with this KN B3
preparation thank you Alejandra
fascinating game just absolutely uh
mindboggling yeah and I think one of the
key reasons why Rook C3 in this position
is not desirable was because the pawn
structure does not get spoiled because
that is one of the massive compensations
that black gets with the Rook C3
sacrifice which is not there in this
position I also feel yes that MV was
probably a little bit taken back and not
expecting the move Knight B3 because
vishy like we mentioned normally goes
back night E2 so he is out of his
preparation as well or he's not exactly
able to remember because don't forget
these guys have so much preparation and
before the game what they see and on the
board they often forget a lot of stuff
that they might not have refreshed right
right before the round exactly and now I
think it's clear that both Wishy and um
vashar are playing out of the book or
out of their preparation but what is
interesting is that even if the computer
does not give a move that Maxine plays
is the best move I mean practically it
is always difficult to to kind of
counter that because you can only make
one move on the board sure you know you
you don't have the option of taking back
so I like that bashia despite
most probably we're going to find that
out after the game is out of his
preparation despite that he is playing
quickly well again he's got such great F
familiarity with the position so yeah so
little nuances here or there aren't
going to disturb him to your point when
you do make this exchange sacrifice
usually speaking this Pawn on B3 is on
A2 and therefore the structure really
does get shattered here
thebly right here the pond the pond
structure is quite nice uh solid as um
Alejandro was saying so what we got is
this position Bishop comes to B4 and now
Bishop G2 Bishop David 2 I think is what
was played so just stopping any ideas of
Rook takes C3 and uh again he wants to
go long castle at some point so he's
going to take out his Queen next and you
think he's going to go long I thought
that uh White was probably Bishop G2
short castles okay if if Black Goes
short castles uh so here the question is
speed of development right okay black
has Gambit at a pawn uh for the superior
de development but then at the same time
he needs uh to find a way of creating
threats if you allow White Queen E2 long
castles or simply uh short castles white
is going to catch up with development
and he's going to hang on to the pawn
for deer life yes now do you consider
yourself a nighter player do you like
blacks or Whit's position so when I used
to play Sicilian against E4 it was
always SW nikov N I actually really
enjoyed playing about having the study
yes but now now it's more E4 E5 because
it's so much to but I have studied quite
a bit of naid off but like I said from
White and I used to just love playing
Bishop C4 mhm uh with with great results
yeah but night off is so much Theory and
like I said just a small inaccuracy
basically means game over and night off
or worse like we were talking I mean in
a position where black did go D5 you
have to have that ability to do
something Dynamic on the spot yes you
know you cannot just make simple
development moves and often you make
moves which are counterintuitive as well
just because they work in a concrete
manner in this particular opening yes
specific to to the tactics at that
moment yes absolutely yeah okay so we
have this position after and we're going
to go to London with Maurice
Ashley
yes so so far you've seen these games
very exciting games you have Rich
opening positions happening on some of
the boards the two Americans may be
facing sort of unlucky seven if you will
I will go to this I wanted to show
another position first this one with
vasiline topolov and Fabiano Carana the
move H4 has been played in a French
Advanced French uh sort of a cheeky move
certainly has been seen in some
variations some structures only move
seven and you see all the action going
on the other games but Fabby has been
thinking for a long time right here in
the tank trying to figure out what to do
next but in it's the other position that
I'm really surprised that hikarin
Nakamura who unfortunately lost
yesterday on his birthday even he's not
showing great form because in this
position this this position has been
seen tons of times and yet he's been in
the tank for quite some time trying to
figure out what to do next looking at
his body language before the game
started they play a video before every
round and Hikaru was the one player who
was deeply analyzing the initial
position he was just sitting there head
in his hands looking at the board trying
to get himself revved up for the battle
but he has found himself in a tricky
situation now already about a half an
hour down on the clock on move seven on
what looks to All rights like a position
he should have seen plenty of times
before in his career so we'll see
whether or not he can get himself back
in form and try to make a run at winning
this Grand chest tour matter of fact he
probably just wants to win a game the
way he played yesterday we'll have more
from London thank you Maurice and queen
takes D4 is really taken hikaro into the
tank and H4 it's true as uh Fabby
Alejandra was pointing out but uh
well explain that one to us Alejandro
why the why the big tank well the thing
about this position is that if you play
normal moves you just get made it so you
have to be a little careful if you for
example play Knight C6 Queen H4 D6 and
you say okay just going to develop my
pieces sometimes in this scenarios when
you go Bishop H6 white simply goes
Bishop H6 Knight G5 Knight D5 takes on
G7 and there's really not much you can
do about it you have to be able to
calculate that you're not getting M it
and in this case there's some
counterplay with Queen B6 that you have
to make sure that actually works uh but
in this position already black has a lot
of resources Knight C6 is by no means
Force I'm going to provide some ideas
that hiar might be looking at first you
could play Knight C6 immediately and say
well your attack doesn't actually work
uh second you could play Queen A5 with
the idea of putting pressure on the C3
three Knight and allowing you to
transfer the queen to uh the H5 Square
in case white goes Queen H4 in order to
counteract the king side attack you
could also go uh instead of playing
Knight C6 you play D6 which is a very
similar idea to Knight C6 but in a
different way you could also play the
move H6 the idea of H6 is that you're
preparing Knight C6 if the Queen ever
goes to H4 I have prepared the idea of
G5 now again I have to make sure I'm not
getting mated after Knight takes G5 and
that the sacrifices don't work they
probably don't but you have to make sure
lastly he can be considering to move D5
which is a pawn sacrifice if I take with
the pawn then Black's instantly better
after Knight takes D5 The Bishop's
hitting the queen and I don't have time
to take on D5 because Bishop takes E3 is
check and I win uh the queen on well I
don't win the queen in the next move you
have Knight D2 but clearly this is not
what Anish is for problem yeah black at
least solves all their problems probably
already it's slightly better for black
as I have Rook d8 coming in the next
move now D5 the uh thing you have to
analyze mainly is Knight takes D5 then
Knight takes D5 Queen takes D5 Knight C6
this is would be just a pure Pawn
sacrifice but you can see how Black's uh
accelerated development gives him plenty
of compensation Bishop coming to E6 Pawn
on C4 and B2 not so easy to defend not
so obvious on how white can develop so a
lot to consider here for hikaro Nakamura
it might seem like you have a 30 minute
think that is nonsense but actually
hikaro has a lot to consider in this
position that as we've seen has not
really been playing before at the top
level of Chess that is very interesting
and we see Anish strolling in to what's
also um you know something think about
give this young man Anish Gary a great
deal of credit he's very theoretical I
mean he's he works very hard on his
chest he's he's a new Papa and so he's
got little one to take care of and maybe
a bit of a distraction but I've always
been impressed by his opening
preparation it's very deep and he plays
some very sophisticated sharp lines and
he's he's also very Savvy about choosing
particular uh openings against
particular opponents in any case what
he's chosen today against hikaro has
worked out
brilliantly because he's going to be so
far ahead on the clock right he and he's
also he also calculates like a complete
machine yes Anish is is so in that way
his preparation is really strong even
though Queen D4 is not a normal
theoretical move it brings us to the
point that in chess in general there is
no one best move in a physician that's
what computers have taught us I think
more than anything and that even
positions that we always thought badly
about that they had resources that we
never you're horrible sveshnikov being a
case in the point I mean you're just
being positionally capitulated but
coming back to hikaru's options here
which we were discussing Yesa uh you
know the move D5 looks so interesting
and I have no doubt that harar is
actually thinking about it very
seriously but after what happened
yesterday with him playing a move like
Knight E2 and blundering that pawn you
know it kind of psychologically plays on
you that you want to be doubly sure I
mean Hikaru is the kind of person who
will not shy of Starting Fire On The
Board a move like D5 he would he would
definitely be inclined to play that but
with given the start that he had he's
probably double in it yeah it's one of
those confidence things when you when
you get stunned with uh being lost as as
early as a dozen moves I mean your
confidence is shaken and so you do
double check and treble check and I
believe that D5 is the mov he's finding
most attractive I I would still bet on
him playing D5 in this okay well that's
definitely suddenly hope for it fire on
the board uh because there are other
safer Alternatives but D5 is definitely
an attempt to quote refute White's play
with Queen takes D4 that's the sharpest
attempt I'll just turn our attention to
our tournament well one of our
tournament leaders Wesley so uh Wesley
so made a move that's not very common in
the Catalan uh we left it about these
parts when Mickey had just uh made this
uh well
uh hot theoretical uh Rook B6 maneuver
and H7 H6 you see this all the time in
in Catalan and I think N9 times out of
10 folks either capture the Knight or
they just Retreat the bishop back one uh
Square to the F4 but this move Bishop D2
now that's a move uh that well I would
not have guessed I mean I could have
imagined Bishop E3 uh eyeballing an
opportunity to play D5 probably not so
good because of Knight E4 and so with
the move Bishop D2 uh basically Wesley
wants to give himself the option of the
move E2 E4 but you look at that Bishop
on D2 and say dude you're just in the
way I want to bring my Rooks into the
center what are you doing on D2 I think
one of the key points in this position
of playing Bishop D2 is of course like
you said the A5 Pawn at some point it
can come it can be a Target here because
the Rook is not on A8 anymore right and
the thing is like once you put your
knight 6 Knight B4 then really The Rook
on B6 becomes a bit awkward and uh
Bishop F4 Bishop B3 are normal Retreats
but they always put the bishop under
pressure with Knight D5 or Knight G4
attacking that Bishop it's like the
problem Bishop you don't know where to
put it right and then it's also it's
also like the problem threat because you
know you can attack the bishop but when
the Knight goes when the bishop goes
back after a move like Knight D5 or
Knight G4 the Knight also comes under
attack right and feels misplaced well
we're going to see how Mickey reacts to
this move he's having a think we're
going to go into a short break see you
soon
[Music]
after I'm Mike maeni manager of the
Cardinals and chess fanatic many people
don't know know that St Louis has a
chess history as rich as its baseball at
the world-renowned chess club and
Scholastic Center of St Louis across
from the World Chess Hall of Fame our
goal is to teach play and promote the
sport come to the Central West End and
experience all that chess has to
[Music]
offer
n
[Music]
a
he
[Music]
e
that is 10 of the world's best players
live from Kensington Olympia London yes
here we are in round two and things as
they would say in Britain are hotting up
uh We've uh after going into the tank
for quite some time Fabiana caruana
finally in response to this
um hyper aggressive move H2 H4 did play
the move as expected Queen B6 6
continuing with the normal French ideas
of attacking the pawn on D4 Knight A3
was essay by vesselin this Knight often
times travels back to the C2 Square
buttressing the pawn on B4 and a very
different approach I like it a very
creative approach by Fabby he traded on
D4 and then posted his Knight onto the
B4 Square basically saying okay this
Knight isn't that great but neither is
the Knight on A3 and at the same time
he's preparing to open up his bishop and
maybe also preparing this Knight to come
to C6 having said all of that this
strategic gamble by topof pays off in
some measure after the move H5 because
now go H6 now yes well H6 is a kind of a
threat and after H6 in response
basically black has not won the F5
Square first Knight because G 2 G4 is
always in the offing and this is going
to be a very tough uh battle for both
players I I think this is one of those
give some take some sort of a situation
where Knight F5 might not be possible
but then after Rook C8 this Knight on E3
is
really yes exactly so imagining some
moves like castles and so forth and so
on but this is going to be a very big
game and again uh caruana very very
close to Magnus Carlson really wants to
put in in a a great performance I do
like the way that Fabiano has handled
the opening I mean it was clear that
after age four he had no idea how he's
supposed to continue but after a think
yes and uh also talking about another
player who went into the tank was say
CaRu Nakamura
against he played the move Queen A5 with
ideas as Alejandra was saying not only
uh discovering attacks against against
the queen on D4 but essentially
preparing to meet a move like Queen D4
with a defense of Queen H5 reaction I
think in general yes not just for Queen
H4 but black wants to transfer the queen
to H5 after it is there on A5 whether
white plays Queen H4 or not black wants
to go Queen H5 and if white doesn't do
anything then he can also think about D6
Bishop H3 ideas himself well exactly if
the queen is over on the on the king
side as well and let's go to that uh
sharp Knight ORF that had uh been uh yes
and we did see a long Castle as well you
know the B and B3 B2 and C2 I just
really like the King on the queen side
because it just is such a good Fortress
I mean so much harder for black to break
through shock Castle would have been a I
mean with the queen on B6 it's anyways
impossible it was impossible it was
impossible but I do feel that White's
King is safe on the queen side well
let's go back to exactly what happened
so we saw this Pawn Sacrifice by mvl D5
takes Bishop B4 Bishop G2 Queen B6
essentially denying white the
opportunity of castling short Bishop D2
E4 Queen E2 castles castles Knight C5
and King B1 tucking the white king into
bed over here on the queen side don't
forget white is still at this moment
upon up and not only that but he's also
very fast with his side yeah G5 it's
looking to my eyes at least very
favorable asked that probably black goes
Rook sorry go on yeah no not at all go
ahead I'm just trying to think that what
is Black's way Rook d8 is what comes to
my mind right you want to attack this D5
pawn and hopefully try to win it back
right I mean Alejandra will tell us
whether it's it's right way or not but
just looking at the position Rook d8
comes naturally to me and then you've
got G5 so I take on D5 or maybe I take
on C3 first because if I take D5 you
take on e4 no I'll take on d i i my E4
Pawn is also hanging right o very very
nice that's a good Pawn to take too
because that'll open up my Bishop on G2
so you wanted to take on C3 immediately
you can't take on F6 cuz I take with the
bishop so you've got to take on C3 good
point uh and now I just take on D5 and
I'm I think I'm kind of happy with black
are you
not I would be I'd be frightened to
death first of all ideas of Bishop G7
and F6 are always in the position but I
think just spank
Bish oh Knight four you're back in the
game darn
it I hate that the knights are always
jumping always jumping cool although I
Can I by the way yesterday we had some
very interesting two nights versus two
in fact Wishy had two nights and this
time he's with the the Bishops right
well let's turn it over to Alejandro
because uh I'm not convinced by mv's
play well yaser uh the computer kind of
agrees with you pretty much says what
White's winning in this position it's
that strong of an advantage it's giving
to the white side after the move King B1
I really don't see anything but the move
Rook fd8 as you were suggesting Tanya
anything else doesn't make any sense to
me you have to start attacking the D5
Pawn so Rook fd8 for example otherwise I
go G5 can I go D6 here you can go D6 you
can also go Rook H E1 is what the
computer is recommending simply
developing a piece saying hey you have
to take on C3 here if you want to get
your Pawn back and that's a concession
why do I have to force you with G5 if
I'm not going to continue the attack
just develop a piece Bishop takes C3
Bishop takes C3 probably Bishop C3 is
not the best maybe you should try to
play A5 and create some kind of
counterplay it's not so clear what you
can do Knight takes D5 Bishop D4 and we
go into a very similar variation that
you guys were uh giving Knight takes G2
and queen takes G2 and the the problem
is actually evaluating this position and
even if I hadn't played Rook H1 and I
play G5 the evaluation is still almost
similar white is way ahead wow the
problem is that you're going to take on
C5 next move and then take on e4 and I'm
basic basically a pawn to the good and I
think that White's King is safer than
blacks maybe a little arguable but I'd
rather take white side of the attack in
this position with my pawns already so
far Advanced so it seems like white has
the pawn and the compensation in this
situation it seems pretty ugly um it all
seems kind of forced though after Rook
fd8 I mean even what you guys were
suggesting G5 takes takes Knight takes
D5 Bishop D4 uh Knight F4 here Queen F2
takes takes and now I have G5 instead of
Rook H G1 it's still very good for white
E4 will fall at some point I'm also
expecting to play G6 this bishop on D4
is quite strong this is also a very
clear Advantage for the white side so it
doesn't really matter how you do it it
seems like vishy is in control I'm not a
big fan actually yaser of the way that
Fabiano is handling the position ah uh
this is more my opinion than the engines
the engine thinks Knight B4 is fine it
prefer Knight F5 or H5 but if there is
one uh opening that the computers don't
understand is usually the advanced
French uh so after night B4 4 H5 H6
Bishop D2 I'm already liking White and
the reason is not so much that I'm going
to Castle I thought the idea King F1 is
very strong in this position the idea
that I have the possibility of bringing
my Rook up on H3 sometimes going to G3
to Target G7 sometimes even to B3 to
exploit some kind of pin down on this
file and after the move A6 which I'm
assuming is to
play Bishop B5 or it's avoiding Knight
B5 I'm not entirely sure what this move
is for so after King F1 which I look
think is very logical you have to find a
way of developing all of black pieces
which is the common problem that you
have when you're down on space as much
as Fabiano is right now and it's not so
clear the reason I don't like the Knight
on before before is that You' kind of
released the pressure on D4 which
allowed him to develop the bishop to D2
notice that when this Knight was here on
C6 the entire point of having this uh
setup is that you cannot develop this
bishop if you develop the bishop you
either lose B2 or you lose D4 when you
put the Knight on before both problems
have magically been solved for white so
this allows me to put the bishop on C3
which is basically its dream position
now that the Knight is not going to be
occupying that square after for example
King F1 I would rather be white any any
time really you already have to be
considering to Long Castle here for the
black side because short castling is
going to be suicide you could consider
keeping the king in the center but this
is not a French type of position where
keeping the king in the center is so
acceptable since you will lack a
coordination of the Rooks to fight for
any of the files with the white advant
in space it's going to be easier for him
to play on both flanks I see that theala
has played the move Bishop C3 which also
looks very logical to me I'd really
prefer black uh White not a huge
Advantage but I think it's a more
pleasant position to play for talo than
for Fabby thank you all very very good
points indeed logical I mean how do you
develop and connect those Rooks and take
out your pieces a big right well I
thought you know because because this
whole idea of fa Fabby of Knight B4
uh playing against the Knight on A3 uh
that's just a very different approach
than what I would do in the French
normally I'm playing Knight F5 and
against
D4 yeah as much pressure on D4 without
question and especially after my
opponent has played the move H4 and I
did see in the position that topof had
played H5 and strategically that's a big
Bishop D2 Bishop C3 so now the Rook on C
file doesn't have much of a role he can
come back Knight C2 as in when he wants
the Knight on E3 looks misplaced but
maybe the Knight on B4 is actually more
misplaced than the Knight on C2 well
it's like what a Black's pieces really
doing White's got the space advantage in
the center and you're not attacking the
center I mean white saying oh that's
okay well how are you going to get any
counter play because I'll control the
center and just keep uh a grip on the
position I also yes like another very
very typical idea in the French is to
try to break with F6 but that is also
not possible in this in these kind of
setups I mean we see F6 all the time in
the French absolutely but here with H5
H6 committed and I mean F6 is going to
be a bit of a task to get but I'm
wondering if that could be Black's only
plan trying to get a successful break
with F6 where else is it coming from you
don't really want to play G5 after the
move H5 is in the board and an echo
interesting echo of his game of
yesterday Michael Adams has voluntarily
traded the bishop just as he did against
leavon Ron and he had this beautiful
Bishop on A7 and he played Bishop A7
captures E3 and then got very nice
counterplay by opening the position for
his two knights here we oh we have a
mace Ashley in London yes
yes it's not often that Lawrence Trent
is called a special guest I think uh
often they try to boot him out of the
place but no la is a dear friend and we
could talk to each other that way
Lawrence welcome to the show especially
in other ways maybe well Lawrence is
actually doing live commentary here in
London we have a big live audience
watching right now and Lawrence it's
yesterday's round frankly was subpar I
mean we saw some blunders that we we
just don't normally see today the games
are much more interesting much more
level um it was subar perhaps from a
playing standard perspective but
actually in terms of an entertainment
perspective it was quite the opposite we
all enjoyed it cuz we actually like to
see blunders ER and the drama but today
you're right uh games seem to be a bit
more mild obviously the maxim bashra
game uh could have been really spicy it
still is but it doesn't quite feel like
he's equalized we'll get to that we'll
get to the game the game let's start
with this one let's start with this one
yeah the first game here now this is
obviously symmetrical kind of structure
and very very equal neither player has
really gone out their way to try and
punish the other from macaroni and
usually very solid yeah they they've
both got immense respect for each other
and they don't normally go completely
crazy against each other especially also
because uh they both won yesterday so a
draw today is hardly the end of the
world for them so I I expect this one to
fizzle out not much not much is going on
at all actually not much to do here in
the pawn inst structure but get let's
get to one that doesn't look like it's
going to be a draw at all Julian Hudson
who's doing commentary grandm Julian
Hobson doing commentary in the VIP room
he's going bonkers he can't even get his
attention off of this game because he
felt like Maxim did not play the
Thematic idea way back here when he
played D5 in this position he was really
I mean it's like and the guy's
apoplectic virtually he wants Rook C3
Rook C3 static that's what you have to
do that's how you should have played and
I think that Maxim is going to regret
not playing Rook C3 if the game
continues the way it looks yeah I mean
the thing is Rook C3 is just screaming
out to be played even you know Julian
Chris they're all EX Dragon players so
they you know Cilan Dragon you you
sacrifice that Rook for the Knight on C3
it's a little different here though
because given vy's level of preparation
in the opening he would not have entered
this line if he had not analyzed it
concretely he was blitzing his he was
blitzing it out so unless you've looked
at Rook C3 very recently and have got a
serious idea in it it's very difficult
to play because you know VI is going to
find the only moves and then you've got
to think on your toe so he tried
something else but the truth is it
doesn't really feel like he's got quite
enough at the moment I feel like if we
shoot forward to the current position
after King B1 um vish's managed to solve
his major problem which was his King
which was in the center it's now tucked
away very nicely on the B1 Square Max's
trying to generate some play in the
center use his kns but really I I feel
like this is just not enough for maxim
and um the computers are agreeing as
well the compu white simply up upon so
unfortunate situation for maxim Vash gra
we'll see what vishy had to say say when
they both come in here for interviews
jumping to the next game we see this one
the leader Wesley so for the grand chest
tour tie for first right now against
England's own Michael Adams this
formation you mentioned that you played
yourself with the black pieces as a
matter of fact I think I had this
position a few months ago after Rook A6
against Victor Erdos people can check
that out um I'd be very surprised if I
was wrong there I'm pretty sure I did
have this position um a very solid kind
of way to approach uh from a black side
but actually what seems to transpired is
Mickey has done something slightly
unusual as we go through the moves this
is all kind of normal actually here was
already a very interesting moment with
Wesley retreating this bishop but yes we
talked about this in the studio that
this bishop D2 is a bit unusual very
unusual because obviously the point of
playing Bishop G5 is that when it gets
hit by H6 is you take the Knight off so
he did this and then some other stuff
has happened yeah Mickey's exchange on
F3 that's very common but here he played
the move Knight C6 again very kind of
unusual us normally you put the pawn on
C6 to keep a very solid structure so I
don't know whether this is a case of
Mickey now really going for it or he's
just trying to drum up play still looks
like White's a bit better just optically
but again looks like there's a full game
ahead yeah we saw that big trade Bishop
takes on F3 Bishop for Knight is a
critical critical trade and usually a
light Square Bishop trading for a knight
you'll attack on the dark squares and
that's what he's done thematically uh
what he didn't do yesterday by the way
when he did Play Bishop takes night
against aonian so now to
your boy Fabiano Carana we know that you
you and he are good buddies you are his
manager for quite some time the French
defense he he's he's thrown that out
recently a couple of times now it looks
like um yeah he uh he used to play this
on a more regular basis actually and uh
uh I remember a big win he had against
Mickey Adams in an Olympiad when he was
actually uh back then not playing for
the US playing for Italy um and it was
his main weapon and he got a lot of good
results but as I said in the live
commentary here you when you get to the
very very top top level you have to uh
you have to mix up your repertoire and
have something really solid which is why
he was playing E4 E5 a lot um some
boring Berlin some boring berlins and
that kind of stuff and sometimes you
have to do that but today he really felt
like going for it against vesselin who
is very unpredictable as we know it
really depends how he is on the day I
have to say though looking at this
position I feel like why should be a bit
better but maybe Fabiano is doing just
about all right I don't quite the fact
that Fabiano's King isn't quite
developed yet um wi's got a very easy
plan of just shifting over with his King
to F1 or G1 if he wants and the question
is you know if Fabiano would play a move
like Bishop E7 simple developing move
what do you do against Rook G3 how do
you start defending that G7 Pawn you
have to go passive and also these
Knights they're kind of a bit I don't
know they're treading on each other's
toes really so I'm not a massive fan of
the position maybe there's a way to
release the pressure for Fabiano but in
general I would say take white although
far from Clear these two played in the
champion showdown in St Louis recently
and and vilin famously sacrificed a
piece for just about no reason and ended
up winning that game so Fabby with the
black pieces of that game as well no
doubt looking for some measure of
Revenge but let's get to the last game
we have and this one after a very long
think quite surprisingly so this move
this unusual move Queen takes D4 looks
as though hikaro went into a big tank
and came out with this idea of not
letting the White Queen go to this side
let's just come up to date because we
haven't seen these mve look at this an
immediate trade defanging this the
position it doesn't look like it's that
interesting right now this position it
seems like his his big analyses paid off
yeah I mean it it was a I think it was a
a testy kind of move Queen 6 D4 by Anish
I think he was just uh flirting with the
idea of swinging over to H4 and he
thought well Hikari is going to have a
bit of a think here gain some time but
the position we've now got on the board
is one where Anish will be happy because
it's really risk-free for white he's
just got a bit of pressure along the
long diagonal he'll develop his pieces
very calmly and um this this looks like
a boring draw yeah I don't think it's a
draw yet I think there's still some play
I mean white has
always draw oh uh let me think about
that off a uh but no I mean look I mean
objectively of course it's you know it's
it's nothing Mass for white at all but
in these structures it's always it's
neutralizing this bishop on G2 he's
going to play Bishop D2 and he might go
B4 who knows obviously it's just close
to equal but I still think there's a
game ahead indeed well thank you so much
Lawrence I you got lots of work to do
again International Master Lawrence
Trent and also International dance
expert Lawrence Trent you can bust out
some salsa moves at any moment guys back
to you thank you Maurice and Lawrence uh
I was listening to Lawrence there
talking about his uh pese Fabby in Fab's
position and he was really hedging his
bets like oh it's not that bad it's kind
of interesting but when I'm looking at
position scary for black absolutely
there's no play in the position for for
black White's just got this massive
Central grip and it's it's developing
into a sort of position that vesselin
really likes to play oh absolutely I
mean they just mentioned that both of
them were here for the champion Showdown
and in fact um um they exchanged wins
where veselin won that brilliant
Sacrifice game where he gave the piece
and then just went on with H4 in fact he
made H4 even in that game which good
point which was just an incredible move
there yes um yeah and this position also
seems to develop in a way that velin
really likes where you know full of like
tactical possibilities and not and and
black just seems passive but we do have
a lot of progress because Carana has
gone for longside castling there was no
choice because as uh Lawrence himself
very well uh said that if black were to
uh Castle short side suicide it would be
suicide variation he'd be walking into a
readymade white attack with the Rook
coming to G3 so there was no choice G5
all of that right there was no choice he
had to go long and now black can really
think about the F6
break well not immediately but prepare
for it with Bishop B7 and at some point
because I still
feel like that is where Black's Play
Lies well again I'm I'm of the view that
I don't like this position and that
white is really sitting on black and
black had better to do something and the
the only something that he could do is
play G5 and G6 or F7 and F6 that's it
you're not going to go A5 A4 B5 B4 I
mean there's nothing else to do so
you've got to prepare your yourself uh
for an F6 break and this Rook is just
going to come over here to G3 here it
could also yes just go I mean I really
like to move Rook H3 in such positions
because you can even transfer it you
know to the b or the C5 right and as was
mentioned white is going to go and Tuck
his King over here so you're going to go
Rook C8 perfectly safe on F1 right and
at some moment you really do have to
play F6 but when you do that I mean well
let let's just put it on the board so
you can see it visually this Square G6
is just suddenly like flashing it
screams at you like are you ready to
allow uh such uh lines like night H for
either Knight coming to G6 or The Rook
coming to G6 it seems to me like uh
black is going to be forced to make a
decision that uh could be strategically
losing you want that B on 87 right well
no no question about it and so in these
position positions strategically you
have no choice you have to take this
enormous Gamble and if you don't why
just absolutely sits on the position and
improves his position to a point uh that
it's not just gradual it's it'll be over
another quick moment here just that I I
wanted to say I played this move King F1
and I could do it a different way
actually Tanya here I could play the
move Queen D2 what's the idea is I'm
going to go Queen F4 okay okay so I'm
going to make it really really hard for
you to ever Bishop E8 more or less box
and by box I mean forced of course uh
King comes over to F1 and again uh a lot
of black pieces are
passively uh waiting on the king side
for something to do I mean I think black
has to go something like Rook G8 move
that King away Bishop E7 but I still
feel F6 is it has to happen at some
point in a French it has to the thing is
like this is what is incredible about
the French it looks like everything is
closed especially in the advance but
then suddenly it becomes a crazy
position when you get something like F6
on the board well as a French player I
look forward to those moments when it
when the tie turns in my favor but I'm
saying for the meanwhile uh I think that
vesselin is going to be pleased with the
outcome of the opening this H4 gamble I
consider it a bit of a strategic gamble
has played off and we'll see how the
game unfolds I'm going to turn it over
Al Ro and ask him what's uh peing his
interest Alejandro well yes I'm
analyzing the game between Grand chestor
leader Wesley so with the white pieces
against Mickey Adams and well we had
this fascinating exchange as Maurice
likes likes to say the most important
trade in ch a bishop for a knight and we
had this position in which after Bishop
takes C6 there's a lot of options for
Mickey he can take on D4 he can take on
C6 or he can take on C3 all of them
actually work tactically however after
taking on C6 you're sacrificing this
Pawn on E5 the question would be do you
have enough compensation the computer
say you have some but not enough instead
he play a Lo more logical move Pawn
takes D4 if Pawn takes D4 then I am very
happy to take that Bishop the bishop
really has to retreat and now this is
the key difference I think where
computers are just stronger than humans
because here you have the option of
going to F3 or to G2 and for a human
it's really unclear which one is better
sometimes on F3 it'll be better because
you're able to control this diagonal not
a lot ing a knight to G4 and it allows
me to put the King on G2 in which is a
much better position than on G1 however
on the other hand it is a slightly more
exposed Bishop in certain variations and
the computers definitely think Bishop G2
was better than what Wesley chose Bishop
F3 and they have a very concrete line in
mind I'm going to go down the path
Bishop F3 Pawn takes C3 Pawn takes C3 uh
which is a position on the board and
imagine that here Adams plays the move
Bishop D6 which is what the computers
prefer
now if I play rookie D1 in this position
the computers are saying that black has
resource Knight D7 the idea being that
if I play C4 targeting this Pawn on A5
black is just in time to play Queen F6
hitting this guy on F3 King G2 and then
Rook B2 with a certain amount of
counterplay still perhaps a little bit
better for white because of the pair of
Bishops but anything goes in this
position especially once the Knight
reaches the C5 Square however the bishop
had been on on G2 then after Pawn takes
Pawn takes Bishop D6 Rook D1 you don't
have the possibility of playing Knight
D7 as after C4 I'm simply threatening to
win the pawn on A5 you don't have the
possibility of going Queen F6 as I just
kick out your uh Queen first and then
take on A5 and something that I was not
able to do because the bishop was
exposed in this variation on F3 it's the
subtle differences that maybe you might
wonder how are computers so much better
than humans this little details that
just kind of add up I see that mikatas
hasn't played Bishop D6 instead he has
played another interesting move Bishop
to C5 and at the end of the day even
though Bishop F3 was probably not as
accurate as Bishop G2 it's still better
for white you have the pair of Bishops
this bishop is just flat out annoying
and at some point I'm going to be able
to play C4 and attack this Pawn on A5
and even though you would like to play
Bishop B4 against it notice that if this
ever happens and Bishop B4 is on the
board you always have to watch out for
C5 so you have to make sure as black
that C5 is not working and doesn't
basically win a PA on the spot I like
Wesley's position I think he has great
chances to exploit it and pressure Micky
Adams in this position than thank you I
have to say Bishop F3 is quite a
controversial decision yes at in this
position I mean it's a lifetime of
playing against double Bishop in this
position and like we saw what happens is
that just simply white always has this
slight advantage of having two Bishops
in such a position true and again A5
Pawn as well yes and again I just wanted
to mention from the first round game
where uh Mickey gave up this dark squar
Bishop which was s lurking on A7 for
this Knight that was on E3 and then
through forcing play got a very decent
position so you look at this position
and you don't think uh about giving up
this quote beautiful Bishop on F on C6
eyeballing the F3 Knight
and I just think that this move E5 this
whole concept I want to say by black of
Micky's is like sometimes when you're a
little bit uncomfortable with your
position you want to make some forcing
uh decisions to get to a position that
you more comfortable with you like like
you you're not in a comfort zone and you
want to get to your comfort zone and by
trading and forcing the action Mickey
was probably thinking that he was
getting a good position but this move
Bishop takes
C6 also it's not a decision that you
really think about you've got this light
squared Bishop you're thinking more
about oh I want to play D E5 or I want
to play Rook D1 and you want to keep
this bishop both players giving up but
yes in a concrete way Bishop C6 I mean
if you take this bishop back then I've
got this D5 option so in a way I'm not
giving my double Bishop because the next
move I return and coming back to the
point of Bishop F3 Bishop G2 it is a
very very subtle computer difference but
I think in Practical chess it is so
important to not get caught up in these
moments and spend too much time over it
and Victor corcho was one of those
players who would spend 50 minutes
judging whether the bishop was better on
F3 or better on G2 and by the way I
would fall for the very same uh human
move bishop3 Bishop F3 I would play nine
out of 10 times I think everyone would
play Bishop F3 and it's annoying that
Bishop G2 for is the right move for a
very specific tactical uh reason this
reminds me of that other perennial
problem of which Rook you know like to
put the which Rook to get on D1 or C1
and so many players spend so much time
on that decision but what we don't
realize is the difference is so subtle
that it doesn't compensate for the time
that you lose yes especially if you lose
a lot of time and after the captures on
C3 we had a recapture and Bishop C5 and
I think we're now up to date with the
position white has the two Bishops a
little bit awkward uh split pawns on the
queen side but this Pawn on A5 is also
kind of sticking out a little bit like a
sore thumb and um regardless of what the
computer says I'm with Wesley I just
like the two Bishops I like this bishop
on F3 very much no I AG Advantage for
white in my view okay where would you
like to take us time well let's take a
look at our current
standings so we're in the middle of
round two and going into round two
Wesley so Vladimir Kik leavon Aron are
three leaders who won their games
yesterday V ranish Fabiano and vishan
and behind them at Half Point and at the
bottom of the board Hikaru and Michael
Adams who had a very very tough start
especially Hikaru and Mickey who just
blundered away the point but it's still
a full tournament to go and anything can
happen let's also take a look at today's
matchup for those of you who have just
joined in so we've got Vladimir kramnik
versus leavon aronian always a very
solid strategic fight two of our
tournament leaders uh going head to-head
in the second round you bet absolutely
and then there's vessel with Fabiano now
I have to say that weson is one of those
players who does not get very affected
with winning or losing in the previous
round he pretty much goes on the board
and starts aresh which is what we've
seen in his game against Fabiano he's
kind of gone all out with H4 H5 trying
to get his creative aggressive position
not you know trying to heal the wounds
of yesterday by playing something safe
with white we also have Wishy Anand
versus mvl ml does seem to get caught up
in his opening preparation in a night
off for which he's super famous but
Wishy
also known for his superior opening
preparation seems to be in the driver
seat at the moment driver seat at the
moment and it's Anish versus Hikaru a
slower game that we've got it's gone
into an end game Queens are off the boat
I still like White's position slightly
slightly and as Wesley so against Mickey
Adams is as we saw so seems to be in a
very very good situation right now with
the two Bishop position the pawn on A5
even though the computer suggest that
black has got enough to compensate for
that with white spawn structure yeah and
it's all about Wesley so wow uh he's
just played magnificently here on the
grand chest tour this is the fourth and
final edition of the
2016 and we have some breaking news that
I really really I'll I'll let you I
don't want to steal your thunder here
but this is a big news everybody we're
talking about the
2017 the next
cycle uh oh but you just have to hold on
to it but it's not going to too long yes
absolutely but talking about Wesley and
the second edition of grand chest which
is about to come to an end I mean what
an incredible run now I think what his
differentiated him from the rest of the
field has been his consistent
performance throughout whether it was
the rapid events winning the singfield
cup he hasn't had a bad event in any of
the GCT tournament absolutely no Wesley
has been remarkably consistent and what
he did at the singfield cup going
undefeated in such a great field and
just seemed to take his opportunities he
was very very good at limiting his
opponents uh attacking chances while
taking full advantage when the opponent
said okay I'll give you an
opportunity and here we go with the
grand chest T points by the way talking
about the grand Chester points I also
want to just run through the viewers
who've just joined us about how it
really works yes exactly so you've got
four events in the grand chess store
that was Paris Len singfield Cup and the
final won the London chess classic now
how it works is that the players earn
Grand chest St points based on their
final rankings in each of these events
exactly and they eventually add up to
decide who is the winner of the grand
chess tour now it's also $100,000
$50,000 bonus prize right for the grand
chest or winner and what's also
interesting is that the players can pick
three of their top scores if they played
in all four events they take the three
best events right they'll drop their low
score and in that way we see that Wesley
so has got a total of 30 points a huge
huge gap from him and on second spot is
leavon Aron and Hikaru Nakamura but what
is interesting is that it's actually
only Hikaru Nakamura who can overtake
vesley by finishing clear first in
London chess classic that's simply
despite having leavon aronian on second
spot that's simply just because the
points add up in such a way that Hikaru
is the only one who can take him down
with the top three scores so to help our
viewers looking at that chart look at
hikaru's score in Luen he scored four
points now imagine that he were to score
13 in London he dropped that score of
four in replaces it with four with 13
which is 11 so the difference being 11
so you take that 212 you add 11 now if
you take pardon me nine pardon me uh you
get up to 30 uh
five5 now if you take leavon score and
at 13 but you're only dropping a six yes
that is and that's why hikaro could
mathematically pass Wesley but Wesley uh
again you look at those Len uh sinkfield
scores and you go wow just very
consistent in Len he finished second
only behind Magnus cson I mean that was
also a great event that he had and
exactly uh and that's how that works
everybody right I mean and but the is
complet completely open for the second
spot anybody above V
Max and Le are all in contention for
second place which is a big $50,000
bonus and just to point out Vladimir kic
is not crashed and burned here okay he
did Crash and Burn Harris and Len but uh
health reasons the bad bat forced him
out of sinkfield he didn't get a zero at
the Z field he simply did not
participate Peter fidler uh came in that
last minute replacement for him right
and well this year at the London chess
classic our Wild Card entry is Mickey
Adams I've got to say though about the
Wild Card entries for this year's gcd
they haven't performed exceedingly well
I mean in all three events we've had
them finishing at the bottom of the
table so it was swidler it was Laura fr
and they and and it was Magnus Carlson
and it was
Magnus so you're really close on this
except Magnus who won it and then
decided not to play in I mean he was not
part of the the world championship which
is finished right so hopefully Mickey
Adams will be able to well last year
Mickey was justify the white entry and
definitely last year I think Mickey went
through the whole competition undefeated
yes he drew all of his games he didn't
win any games and so this loss uh in
round one was really a setback for
Mickey he doesn't like nobody likes
losing but that wasn't a very nice one
that was not a nice way simply because I
think he played a really good game and
it was
it was such an Overlook on his side and
also let's not forget that it was funny
because it was a very Elementary Fork
that he missed in round one but he also
missed it the the move before you know
that idea of Queen D4 so that when you
take the Knight on F3 he goes Queen G4
and your knight on H5 and King on C8 but
he said in his after postgame interview
that he missed that as well so it was
just a day of missing folks for him yeah
Elementary tactical mistakes and let's
turn it over to Alejandro to ask him
Alejandro which game is uh peing your
interest once more well yeah there's a
couple of games that I'm taking a look
at first of all I'm trying to contact
marce so I can get my 10 onone odds
there because I really like gir's
position despite what Maurice is saying
it's just a pleasant advantage that it's
annoying to play with black for example
in this position if I just develop by
Rook you develop your Bishop let's say
to B7 do you want to put it on A6 and
just go B3 there's no real Attack on the
C4 Pawn so I'm assuming you're going to
put it on B7 but here you have to watch
out I have ideas of C5 if you ever take
I take with the kn and you can see
everything is hanging you can't really
do this but allowing this Pawn to
survive here is also quite annoying the
bishop will go to E3 and start attacking
the pawn on B6 Black's counterplay is
kind of lacking it's not that black is
really that much worse it's just
annoying to play with black compared to
playing with white White's moves are
really obvious you develop your pieces
and a push C5 at a appropriate moment in
the bad case scenario it kind of Fizzles
into a draw in a good scenario black is
going to be suffering quite a bit so I
like playing with white white in this
position as I said not a huge Advantage
but I like white in giri against
Nakamura don't forget that they've only
played 11 moves of Chess and he cars
down to 57 minutes on the clock as we
see giri trying to make the most out of
his position he knows it's Pleasant he
just wants to make sure that he's able
to grind out at least a little bit out
of the position he doesn't want to let
his fizzle out another game that I'm
looking at is of course Fabiano Carana
here against veselin toov and I'm not a
huge fan of a couple of toal's moves for
example this battery that he set up with
Bishop C3 and queen D2 I didn't like it
so much first of all because it caughts
The Rook out of the third rank here on
the queen side second because I'm not
really sure why the queen is on D2 uh
this Knight on B4 seems like it's really
rock solid so it's not going to go
anywhere instead of this I preferred
once uh Fabiano castled to actually
bring the Knight back because it
emphasizes how badly played an it on B
before is since A3 becomes a huge threat
and now it's kind kind of awkward for
black to defend against it you could
either play A5 which we weakens your
king side Queen side sorry or move the
Knight away but you don't really want to
move the KN away just put it on C6 uh
after Queen D2 I think it's high time
for Fabiano to actually do something
active and I'm starting to like his
position after the move F6 now that my
King's all the way on B8 I don't really
worry about this too much Pawn takes on
F6 Pawn takes on F6 you don't have the
move uh Queen F4 check because after E5
white black simply getting a huge in in
this position notice that because the
Rook is still on H3 I never moved it
away the bishop is now targeting this
this already looks quite ugly for the
white side so I like the idea of
breaking this Center uh uh The Rook on
H3 is an annoying position for white
this allows E5 on the next move really
justifying the powerful KN Knights now
on C6 and B4 as the Knight on B4 is
covering the D5 Square I don't like this
battery it's just not doing very much F6
I think is a key break in every Advanced
French and in my opinion this is the
time to do it for Fabiano well if there
is a time this is the time no I I
completely agree I mean F6 has to be
done and but you know coming back to
this point of a move like Queen D2 again
yes Knight B1 looks really great but I
think the idea of Queen D2 trying to put
it on F4 is such a human way to play as
well and if you want to go Knight B1 A3
you think that maybe you can wait with
that but just to develop a bit more with
Queen D2 and put the queen on F4 and
stopping F6 but tactically F6 is
possible at this very moment and that's
the whole point these guys are so good
in their calculations they're uh hyper
sensitive to Tactical opportunities and
queen D2 Queen F4 um while logical you
sit there and go okay this night on B4
let's take advantage of let's go A2 A3
but again now we've got the big breaking
news Tanya take it away big big news for
our chess fans so the this uh 27 2017
Grand chest store has been announced but
there are so many positive changes uh
yes firstly a fifth new event has been
added to the Grand chest store this is
going to be a blitz rapid event right
here in St Louis so for the 2017 Grand
chest store we've got three rapid and
Blitz events Caris Len and the St Louis
new brand new event and our two
classical events the sinkfield cup and
the London chess classic so five events
are going to make up the 2017 tour what
is also extremely exciting for chess
fans is that in the rapid and Blitz spot
of the tour there are going to be four
Wild Card entries exactly and the
sinkfield cup and the London classic
there'll be one single wild card entry
for those two events in the other three
events four players which means a much
widening of the player pool and we'll
see some other chest stars getting into
the action that's not where it ends the
priz money of the entire tour has been
increased to
$1.2
million that sounds good to
me we're not getting any of that so time
to polish up my chest skills what do you
say guys I know why that sounds good to
you but it is what's the over and under
here yes no but so very exciting news
for all of us five big events now just
talking about the grand chess store I
mean the whole idea the whole concept
behind this store is to bring the best
of the Chess World to the audience
exactly what we're seeing here in London
this is a fantastic event and the
superstars that are playing
here it's marvelous it just aims at
popularizing the spot spreading it
bringing the best out of it and one of
the ambassadors the main ambassador of
the grand chest store is Gary Kasparov
who is who is basically a mirror image
of everything
that the door stands for you know with
his work in popularizing and spreading
the game which is exactly what this
store aims for yes um I mean instead of
four we get five events instead of 10
players we're going to have 13 players
in the rapid and Blitz section exactly
what more could we ask for Alejandra
what more could we ask for well the
rapid and Blitz are still temp players
but we will have a lot of different wild
cards to be added to the tour that's
what I'm personally very excited about
this these players that perhaps haven't
really broken into the top 10 yet but
are just outside or they're coming up
and running and I want to see some new
faces here and I think that they're
going to give these guys who are
undoubtedly the best in the world a good
run for their money people that have
been doing very well this year I can
think of for example Yan pyasi from
Russia had a fantastic year going from
you know a decent 2720 to almost a top
10 player in the world breaking through
2760 that's a huge pH to see I want to
see in the Blitz and Rapid uh lanir
Dominguez from Cuba who was a former
World Blitz Champion I think that we
have a bunch of interesting faces that
can be brought into the tour and I'm
excited to see who the wild cards will
be for every single one of the rapid and
Blitz sections I think it's going to
just add to the excitement on the board
to have this broader mix of players
absolutely I agree wholeheartedly with
you Alejandro wholeheartedly by the way
uh after this move Rook H1 E1 won by
Vish and nand in his game against mvl
something we had anticipated quite some
time ago uh by the way it seems mvl has
just gone into a tank as he's uh the
awareness is just uh kicking in that
well he's a p down and he's not going to
get it back anytime soon uh what's your
take on this position yeah I hate
Black's position just simply I mean we
can analyze it all you want but the
thing is after Rook H1 which is a very
nice move in my opinion because after
this move Rook H E1 you start putting
the pressure on the E4 pawn and the
thing about this pressure is that it
forces Black's hand if white doesn't do
anything you can imagine that Maxim
might go A5 A4 start to slowly bother
white king he might even have to go A5
anyway and sacrifice something on the on
the center but if you force his hand to
play this line with Bishop takes C3 it
does feel like Black's position is just
bad you're going to be facing off
against either the par of Bishops or
you're going to be facing a major P end
game where your King's a little bit weak
and you're down a pawn very unpleasant
choices honestly I think that from a
practical view you might want to go A5
and hope that A4 works but right now
this is what Maxim is doing hoping thank
you Alejandro uh turning to another big
uh game between our tournament
co-leaders we have Vladimir cranic
leavon ronian not too much to talk about
because the Symmetry in the position 44
22 um very equal is uh type of position
however this is the position where
Vladimir uh he likes the quiet strategic
channels of of play he when forced he
can play tactically extraordinarily well
but this is really his strength I think
is playing these uh semios close
positions these level positions and just
trying to make something and he's so
good he's so good at it okay we've just
seen this move Bishop C5 and you think
to yourself well nothing particularly is
going on but then when you take a deeper
closer look you sit there and go well
what about the move E5 well first of all
you you you have a discovered attack
against this bishop on B7 you're you're
attacking the Knight so a move like
Bishop takes G2 you stop yourself from
doing that because it takes so you
automat aut atically say I'll put my
knight on D5 and I'm very happy and now
you think okay I'm really stand well
with black till you see this move Knight
F5 and then you start to think well wait
a minute I don't want to allow this
Knight to pop into D6 anytime soon
opening up this diagonal okay after
takes takes takes Rook takes you think
to yourself okay I've got Queen E6 I'm
really really happy till you see this
move Rook D1 and then you start to ask
yourself am I worse am I better is it
serious you don't know you know you've
got the double pawns but you know that
your opponent controls the open file and
it's these types of judgments these very
small uh positional considerations that
really separates uh in my view Vladimir
karnick and makes him such an
exceptionally challenging opponent and a
great match player too by the way I
think he's just uh a tournament player
he's won a lot of tournaments don't get
me along but it's a match play where
he's really really a scary guy his
preparation is also one of those things
which is his very very strong point and
with Vladimir you know he always comes
up with an improvement in his
preparation so players even the top
players are afraid of going into the
line that they feel he's prepared
because it's very obvious that he is
he's got an improvement in his hand even
if it is a slight slight Improvement yes
he's constantly working on the game
which is obviously you got to do it to
maintain that level and this reminds me
of what happened yesterday as well I
mean he's just got a position that he
enjoys playing maybe it's not much today
you know and it's still Black's not gone
wrong exactly exactly but it's the kind
of position that he just enjoys playing
and he feels very much at home exactly
and while we're watching a lot of our
players rack their brains today and now
it's time for our audience to do the
same so log on to chess24.com and you've
got the puzzle of the day waiting for
you we'll be back
[Music]
soon until recently chess was like
this chess 24 brought you this live
interactive broadcasts from Top
tournaments with computer analysis and
video commentary by the likes of yan
Gustafson Lawrence Trent and Peter
fidler
a Play Zone where you can take on
opponents from all around the world
24/7 interactive beginners courses
ensuring you pick up the basics fast
while having fun a tactics trainer to
sharpen your Chess By solving puzzles
adapted to your level hundreds of
interactive videos letting you watch and
learn from Star players such as Vish
Anand Peter Sidler pacoo and who you
fan you've given up on that outdated
computer that's why there are more
reasons to use chess 24 on mobiles and
tablets full Play Zone access including
pre-move a tactics trainer so you can
stay sharp wherever you are computer
opponents you can challenge even when
you're not online live broadcasts of top
chess
events and the half it's free well
that's half true most features are free
but limited for registered members you
can step up to premium membership and
gain unlimited access to our video l
library that and much more see you at
chess24.com
[Music]
[Applause]
he
[Music]
[Applause]
n
[Music]
he
hello and welcome back we are well into
round two of the London chess classic
way more level games than yesterday
where we saw a lot of Peace dropping and
a lot of quick
finishes definitely players are feeling
a lot more settled in to into the game
which is what aronian spoke about after
his uh match that the first rounds are
always so nerve-wracking and anything
can happen right the opening Jitters as
you might say and for him he he
especially said that he is a notorious
slow starter so he was happy to get this
first round and to get a win uh he
really felt good about that even if he
said it was undeserved right no well
he's not the only one who's
uncomfortable playing first rounds I
would say it's 90% of the chess players
who do feel the Jitters whether it's an
open tournament or a closed tournament
and it's just so important to get over
the first round in a positive way just
the way he did yes because it kind of
sets the mood for the rest of the
tournament without question I mean and
again we talk about Wesley slow our
grand chestor tournament leader uh
getting a full point against Hikaru
Nakamura his closest rival uh those
first round uh Jitters just went out the
door with that victory
and we have uh during the break a kind
of a controversy broke out here on the
set as a couple couple of the players
went into a tank most specifically Anish
G Anish had a Anish pardon me I should
say had a position right here where he
spent about 30 minutes more or less
coming up with a move Bishop G5 and the
big controversy on the set is what is he
thinking about there's just a lot of
moves in the position that uh are
interchangeable do you start with a move
for example like Rook D1 keeping all
your options open do you have uh as um
Alejandra was pointing out you do also
have ideas of B4 and C5 in the position
getting a queenside expansion B3 Bishop
B2 B3 Bishop B2 and so he was looking
very deeply into the position and trying
to uh say to himself what was his most
ideal peace peace config
exactly his his setup and he eventually
chose Bishop G5 which funnily enough to
me uh was probably my third candidate in
the position I think my I would have
played Rook D1 probably in a Blitz game
uh because I just know that the Rook is
going to be well placed on the defile
and taking the decision with the bishop
later on because you don't know whether
you want it on the A1 h8 diagonal or you
want it on G5 or F4 or where exactly uh
so but you definitely want the Rook on
D1 right you always know you're going to
want the Rook on D1 another completely
different idea different approach into
the position was also to play E2 uh E4
with the idea of getting in a quick E5
if you can do that and get your knight
to D5 then it's just smashing again even
if you did go for that uh approach your
Rook would be well placed on D1 in any
case he did Play Bishop G5 and I I
suspect he did it with a very concrete
idea in mind that there is a like for
example let's say Bishop B7 just to
throw out that move and we do have a a
nasty little tactic That You Better Be
watchful of Knight comes to D5 attacking
the bishop on F6 you want to re retain
the dark Square Bishop but you cannot
thanks to this move Knight takes E7
check and suddenly there's a big
discovery on this bishop on B7 so that
would just snab a pawn so uh Bishop G5
has a tactical Nuance to it yes you know
just taking the point forward about
Anish taking a big think in that
position which a lot of us would wonder
watching this game that why is he
thinking so much I think in ch in
general it is so important to recognize
those situations where you should take
time and where you shouldn't take time
because a lot of us me included come
into a lot of time trouble because we
don't take those decisions properly now
in this kind of a in this kind of a game
I mean it's clear that this position has
been reached pretty quickly for from
anisha's side but now he's got to decide
where to place his pieces so it's
definitely one of those moments which
are going to sort of dictate the
direction the game takes without
question and that is one time it it can
be a different POS it's always a
different position for everybody but
those are the times when you want to sit
down and take a think and really plan it
out because once you've made that plan
you're able to Blitz out the next few
moves exactly and I I think about a lot
of top chess Grand Masters Alexander
grishuk Victor kch who were was
Notorious at
mismanaging their clock and getting into
time trouble consistently time after
time uh whereas I think of a player like
for example leavon aronian who plays
rather freely quickly and is really in
time trouble even vishy for that matter
and vishy well at one point in his life
he was the rapid
yes well and that's an an unusual site
in the game of Vladimir cnick and
leonian both players away from the table
sometimes Mother Nature Calls uh to
their game by the way I think that this
was actually another one of those
moments where Vladimir went into the
tank when we had left it I I had
considered the move E5 Knight D5 and I
was looking at Knight F5 another
approach that Vladimir could could have
have taken is you see this bishop on C5
it's kind of vulnerable to a B3
B4 uh type of maneuver uh hit I want to
say so the move Knight C2 was also very
suggestive to my eyes because you're
opening up this bishop on B2 uh in
principle you're not very happy when
your pawns get doubled so you want to do
something about that would go Queen E7
anywhere Queen E7 any anyway o uh you do
have
I'm uh that's getting a little bit scary
I thought it was going to provoke E6 E5
it does but I don't know if it's
work7 okay well my first inclination
would be to take this guy you can't
really take with the queen because B4 oh
no F2 is hanging o you could take with a
no you you can go E5 now well I'm afraid
there's a queen takes F2 yes I can still
take Queen F2 that's right ooh okay
that's a tricky so I have to get I have
to play B4 first okay so take I take and
I grab the pawn and you grab the pawn
and I'll grab your well if I grab the
Knight you'll take with the pawn and I
don't see the PA up yes
well okay I'm always I like this queen
on E7 in general because you know you've
kind of connected your the whole
question with our question the queen on
E7 is good Tanya but the question is uh
can you afford these double pawns over
here let me just explain why I think
that you should be very uh yes careful
is a very good word and good neutral
word there because there is this check
King and there's a move like Queen H4
attacking this Pawn if you go King G7
you're walking into this shot of E5 oh
Queen H4 I was about to say I was about
to take on SX Queen H4 okay so after
King G7 Rook
D1
to oh you still have Queen D4 I I'm not
getting exactly you're trying to get but
yes you're not allowing maybe it's not
right the point is that like after
remove like Knight C2 the idea is to
play B4 right and I'm just trying to
think how I can stop it I want my queen
on E7 anyway and of course I mean
Tactical if it's not possible it's not
but you always want to make a move like
Queen E7 stopping your ideas connecting
your Rook I want to play Rook d8 next
move and just a normal position then
you're fine uh of these many choices E5
Knight C2 Vladimir eventually decided on
the Move Knight B5 and again Vladimir
has this way of stirring trouble you
know extracting you know the small
little concessions here and there
obviously as uh in his game from round
one he's eyeballing the D6 Square he's
opening up the bishop now the move Queen
E7 almost seems forced a moment ago I
thought E6 E5 was forced now I see Queen
E7 is but now Vladimir idea of E5 now
yasa well of course E5 I wanted to do
that in that other position where my
knight went to F5 and D6 so E5 comes
Knight D5 comes and let's just take a
quick Gander at the move Knight D6 so
obviously I'm sacrificing a pawn but I'm
doing it for very spe specific reasons
associated with this awesome Oh I
thought specifically because it's not
our game yeah no no no it's this awesome
Bishop on B2 eyeballing that G7 Square
notice that after the move Queen G4 F6
would cost you this Pawn on E6 you're
likely forced to play a move like G6 and
you again this game of Fabiano in The
Showdown in St Louis where essentially
topof sacrificed a peace to get these
dark Square weaknesses is it enough for
pwn my instinct says yes but it requires
careful calculation so lots of stuff
Brewing uh underneath a very a tepid
looking position but out of nothing uh
we seen Vladimir kramnick uh produc
masterful attacking ideas I mean if
white really wants any real chances in
this position he's got to go E5 at some
point yes without question that's the
only real plan that he has to create
something I mean if they're if they're
okay with the way the position is it's
not going to get white or black anything
right no it's not just about maneuvering
at some points you have to take a very
cons consequent action I'm looking at
this position again I don't have to jump
immediately to the square D6 uh Queen G4
could be just one of the one of the
testing ideas as we're we're prefacing
the invasion of Knight D6 uh and if I
can provoke G6 without having given a
pawn I'll always be able to give a pawn
later that's right so G6 maybe something
like Queen H3 again
just you know needling a little bit uhoh
because when the bishop on B2 opens up
and you know you've got G6 already you
have to
of Bishop F2 but it's not working
probably at this point cuz you've got
Rook E2 right Rook E2 and queen d c
probably it's not working but that's a
tactic that you've got to keep an eye on
that Bishop F2 doesn't come at right how
does the computer Alejandro how does the
computer evaluate night be there was a
lot of options there for Vladimir and
did he choose the best one well the
computers don't always evaluate as
precisely some positions and I think
that Knight C2 first of all I want to
say that some you might wonder how do
you come up with move like Knight C2 and
sometimes it's just about pattern
recognition this is actually the same
idea that Fabian Caron came up with in
the game between Magnus Carlson and
Sergey karakin that Serge kakin won in
the recent World Championship Fabiano
Karana analyzed that game and he came up
in a critical juncture where Magnus
played the night to B5 and he considered
that to be a mistake instead suggesting
the idea of playing the Knight to C2 to
support a similar B4 Break um the
computer say that Queen E7 B4 takes
takes takes takes takes takes takes Rook
B1 we pretty much got to this position
uh Queen D4 they like white just a
little bit but it's nothing special
eventually the pawn on B6 Falls and even
though there's some weaknesses on the
king side it's just not enough to really
prove a strong Advantage white retains
something very slight but nine out of 10
this will be a draw um Knight B5 is an
interesting try after Queen E7 the
computers are definitely suggesting to
go E5 as as you guys are suggesting uh
now this is a double-edged weapon
because I don't think you guys actually
considered that it is possible to take
on G2 uh it looks suicidal but it's
actually very double-edged after Pawn
takes on F6 Queen goes to B7 in order to
defend this bishop otherwise black is
just lost and the idea is that you're
targeting uh your weaknesses here in the
dark squares against the weaknesses on
the light squares now for white the game
becomes very complex as after move like
Knight D6 very very difficult to
evaluate it becomes extremely sharp it
is also possible to not go into any of
this nonsense although white has to
consider it and go Knight D5 as you guys
said after Knight D6 opening up the
Bishops just seems too strong the bishop
is way too powerful but the computers
think that if you play Rook cd8 Knight
takes B7 Queen takes B7 there's actually
not that many problems for the black
side mainly because this bishop is
completely stuck on the B2 Square
against this pawn and although it's true
that there might be some issues with the
D5 square at some point is just not
enough to prove an advantage the
computers are saying that white has a
very minuscule thing as we see that E5
was played and instantly aronian took on
G2 so we're going to go for some sharp
stuff in this game Kik making sure that
he is wow this is going to get he took
this is going to get exciting I mean
right and queen B7 just absolutely
forced yes uh Alejandro wow okay both
players em
embracing Ultra Sharp because yeah this
G this game went checkmates on both
sides right this game went from like
very quiet to very very sharp very
quickly and the reason is that now both
kings are in danger it's very easy to
see how black Senter get checkm under
the dark sores even a move like Queen G4
you have to very very careful of while
the same is true for White's light
squares you can see easily how after
Bishop H1 it's already not obvious how
you're defending against the threat of
Checkmate I mean Bishop H1 you force
something like Queen F1 which is already
very ugly uh Bishop H3 is also of course
a big threat uh you would have to reply
with Queen E4 remember the black has the
pair of Bishop so a trade of Queens will
probably favor the black side taking on
G7 is sometimes not so desirable because
that pawn even though it's a pass Pawn
on this G7 Square protected by the
bishop on B2 actually acts as a shield
for Black's King now I don't have any
way of creating a mating threat which
means that the initiative passes to
Black after Rook fd8 I would say the
black's even better but Pawn on G7 not
really a threat for now and it's
difficult to cover the light squares uh
the computer are suggesting that instead
of taking on G7 they want to play the
move Knight D6 uh the idea is that after
Bishop takes Rook takes I got rid of
your dark sare Bishop which further
weakens these complex on the king side
and allows me to play F3 against a
potential uh idea on this side of the
board the game gets crazy guys for
example after Bishop H1 you have to play
F3 you could play F4 but it's just a
little too weakening F3 is a better move
if you take with a bishop sorry take
with a bishop here then suddenly it's
white that gets the initiative notice
that everything is up to a Tempo Queen
D2 threatening Queen G5 and now because
I haven't taken on G7 I have real mating
threats If instead you take with the
queen in this
position then more tactics you could
play Queen D2 but it's becomes very
unclear I'm not running Queen G5 because
of Checkmate still a possibility you can
even think of a move like Rook takes C6
guys there's a lot of
variations very very sharp it's up to
tactics now this position strategical
considerations are still there but it's
clearly the weakness of the kings that
is going to be dominating the evaluation
of the position now I want to jump
really quickly to a couple of other
games uh that we have neglected to see
this and it's the game between Anand and
mvl that I want to see how it progresses
uh mvl did play the move A5 in order to
try to create counterplay on the queen
side and here is where computers man
they play some of the most amazing
subtle moves i' I can't even think of
the computers want to play the move D6
and I was trying to figure out why are
you giving up this pawn and here's the
reason the computer also would like to
play G5 Bishop takes C3 Bishop takes C3
Knight takes D5 and it thinks that after
Bishop D4 White's a little bit better
but it realizes that after D6 the only
good way of taking this Pawn is really
with the Rook if you take with the queen
then you just run into the bishop uh
Discovery so if you for example take
with a rook then after G5 we get into
the exact same line as the Knight really
has to go to D5 but now I have to move
Bishop E5 winning a Tempo Against The
Rook so you basically Force The Rook out
to D6 now the bishop gains the tempo on
E5 and this gives white an almost
winning Advantage as after retreating on
d8 I have time to take your Pawn on
e4 and this is basically game over as
the attack on the queen s is not going
anywhere and you already have to be very
worried as the black side of going G6 F6
basically getting mated instead of that
uh vishy played the move Queen F2 which
the computers were not so agreeable with
they thought that here Maxim should take
on C3 take on C3 and Knight takes D5
going for a very similar position in
which anyways white is better I mean
even though the computers think that
white lost a little bit of its Advantage
doesn't mean that White's not better
anyways I I have a question sorry I have
a question for you but before that we've
got Maurice in London so let's go to him
and we'll be back on
this we are talking about explosive
games and all these games are getting
interesting now as we start to get a
little bit closer to time control not
quite there yet of course but these
middle games are starting to explode and
this one has definitely exploded the one
between topalov and Fabiano Carana a
rich position chaotic disorganized if
you will in terms of the peace
distribution you see a knight here on A3
The Rook on A1 the King on F1 opposite
side castling imbalance Pawn structure
but Black's position seems a bit more
together if you will you see these
Knights the Queen and Rook all you need
is this bishop to get into the game so
he played first to move Bishop to E8
eyeballing this pawn and now Knight to
H4 yes night is aim to G6 but take a
look at these Knights Rooks not
connected Knights not connected a bit of
a strange position so Fabiano decided
let me leap this bishop into the game
and after Rook G7 D posting up on the
seventh rank he said I don't care E5 and
now the explosion in the middle of the
board E5 for black black is trying to
break through in the center the D Pawn
is currently under threat if you open it
up the game gets wild and when you have
discoordinated pieces as you see here
it's usually better for the side to open
up the game for the side of course with
the better coordination so advantage to
Black right now it looks as though
Fabiano Carana wants to start putting
together a potential streak where if he
does that wins four games in this
tournament he will surpass Magnus
Carlson and become the number one rated
player in the world wow thank you
Maurice uh that game truly has
exploded uh again my initial gut
reaction would be that White's doing
okay after the move Knight F5 but with
this Knight on
A3 um so out of play I would temper any
enthusiasm I might have for White's
position but definitely Fab's F6 was
well timed we've talked about that
constantly that only chance and he's
getting an F6 and E5 theer a French
defense play dream to get
in uh break well yeah this is going to
be a very interesting but just going
back to that position that Alejandro was
analyzing the wishy game with mvl right
he's where we saw Queen F2 instead of
that uh D6 which is recommended by the
you had a question I do have a question
I mean you know you look at this
position you see the pawn on e4 hanging
and a lot of us would want to know why
we can't why are we thinking about D and
why are we thinking about Queen F2 which
was played which just take the pawn so
what what happens my first instinct is
to say well after Knight takes E4 Knight
takes E4 Bishop takes E4 uh I'm a little
bit concerned about this move A5 A4
agreed white is two pawns up but when I
start looking at White's King you don't
really want to capture this Pawn on A4
because you're inviting bad things to
happen B on B2 on the other hand you're
not really enthusiastic about black
capturing on B3 either as that would
really uh weaken your King's position so
so let's just take this for yeah for
example if I took on B4 Now by all means
Bishop Queen takes B4 can I go Queen D2
yes or you can go guys Queen C4 oh yeah
Queen C4 even better Queen C4 is game
over
oops that's not good Queen C4 have
completely missed okay so let's take a
look at this Knight takes
E4 you have to take on e4 with the F
Knight but then you have to play Rook
sorry so I just wanted to move my queen
then Knight takes E4 Knight takes E4
Bishop takes E4 Rook E8 I can either go
Queen F2 or queen F3 right yes that's
correct so what's
better Queen F2 uh pinning the Knight so
that the pawn the bishop on e4 isn't
hanging or queen F3 I suspect after
Queen F3 black is going to play along
those lines of A5
A4 not completely convincing two-on
Advantage is a two-on Advantage you
better be sure that you're Landing over
there some compensation yes because
otherwise it's just lost there right
there's a queen
B3 uh cutting across after I take on A4
and Knight a there's a queen B3 defense
but there was also that Queen F2 move
yes I like Queen F2 you know opening
that night definitely um well I will
let's again just continue this line
because I think it's a very good
question to ask I'm a pong grubber and I
would definitely be looking at your move
Knight takes E4 and wondering why he
shouldn't do it it has to be associated
with a line uh of A5 A4 again in this
case after you take I'm definitely not
trading
Queens want to do something still not
over though I've got Queen D4 right
Queen D4 you do
indeed uh there's all these pins in the
position but it's I don't seem to be
able to take advantage of them I don't
know exactly why I'm not able
to that's not the real move I want to
play but Queen A5 does least have an
idea of both Knight takes E4 as well as
Knight takes
A4 um
I just don't know are you going to be
comfortable with your king being
attacked maybe you are you still have
this move Queen D no you don't D2 is
hanging by the way so I've either got
Rook D4 or Rook E2 two options so let's
go with Rook D4 Rook D4 Knight A4 Queen
to D2 looks very logical I must say um I
cannot afford to trade Queens of
course but on4
anything Queen Rook you tell me uh I'm
getting refuted what was wrong with
Knight takes E4 Alejandra
nothing nothing I I thought there was a
reputation about D no just computer
simply thinks D6 is even stronger right
but you can take the pawn it does give
black a little bit of an initiative that
line I'm just going to continue it for
you guys uh here Rook D4 you're
suggesting right yep Knight takes A4
here Queen D2 is actually no good uh you
are running oh my God Knight C3 Knight
three yes Pawn takes E3 and then of
course Rook A8 you're getting made oops
uh but if you play it with Queen E3
instead the idea being that after Knight
C3 takes Rook a have King C1 King D2
um yeah white is facing a little bit of
a some difficulties after Rook a there's
still some threats down the a file so
it's not so clear yet actually after the
move A4 back here in this position the
computer wanted to play B4 for some time
uh enticing you to take on D4 and then
go Rook D4 keeping the a file closed and
it says that white is better in every
every variation uh it's just not as
clear as some of the other possibilities
that Anand had Queen F2 for example was
even less clear it did want to grab the
pawn more than it wanted to play the
move that vishy played but after the
move Queen C7 which Maxine played we
still have a double edged position the
thing is that luckily for maxim and we
were talking about this the other day uh
yesterday when we were talking about the
saw against Nakamura game in which uh we
just gave Nakamura up for dead because
he didn't have any counterplay this is
not the case uh Maxim is definitely
worse and he's down upon and every
strategical element is against him
especially the fact that he has the pair
of Bishops in the long run but he does
have counterplay he does have something
to L uh grab on to on the queen side in
order to push forward some kind of
initiative so it's still a double-edged
position in that sense VII has to be
still very careful I love his position
but he still needs to be precise we have
more insights from London with Maurice
Ashley yes you know sometimes when
things go well they go really well and
when things go badly they go really
badly and we see Nakamura yesterday he
just played uh this awful move Knight to
E2 and normally this guy is one of the
greatest tactical Geniuses of Our
Generation uh some people might even
think of all time he the way he plays
chess is pure tactics maybe
strategically there might be some issues
but but from tactical standpoint he
finds everything he's just a beast and
he can do it in bullet chest he can do
it with only one minute on his clock
this position and this position the move
that the computer is screaming about was
the move D5 and this looks very thematic
try to trade off this Pawn but the
tactics make it look funny because it
looks like you're attacking this and you
you might end up with an isolated Pawn
on the Square however there is the
intermetzo Knight to D4 with the threat
of Rook C3 Rook C3 and Knight takes on
E2 not an easy move to meet and the
engines are already giving this as
triple zeros that the game is completely
equalized in fact and Nakamura would
have been just fine and after
liquidation the game would end would
lead towards a draw instead he played
the move Knight to E8 which is the kind
of move you just don't even want to play
putting your KN on the back rank just
trying to stop a a piece from going in
to the D6 Square it's just an ugly
looking move and not typical of the
great player that Nakamura is so you've
got to wonder is he a little bit out of
form coming into this event after
yesterday's game certainly after a move
like 98 I don't think he's trying to win
this game and after ag4 that giri play
the in are saying better for white now
so it looks as though even the great
ones suffer setbacks from time to time
in
tournaments I feel that's a confidence
issue
yes looks like like Hikaru got rocked
yesterday I mean it's a very non- Hikaru
move to go 98 like you were talking I
mean Hikaru is known to be all about
tactics aggressive play starting the
fire on the board a move like D5 would
be something that you'd expect him to be
able
to and calculate and bit that in fact a
lot of hikaru's critics often point out
that it's it's the compromise he makes
with like fundamental strategic chess
choosing a lot of tactical variations
yes uh they use that argument against
him so a move like 98 is very very
against a typical hekaru yeah it's not
in character there's no question about
that
uh well well we do have we've got eight
of the world's best players in London
but there are two missing Magnus Carlson
and serge karakin who were busy playing
the world championship match let's hear
it from our players what they thought
about the
match the world championship just ended
were you surprised by anything that
transpired
there uh yeah it was surprising that U
Magnus was not showing his best play
biggest strength of Magnus is how
consistent he is and he got some uh very
good positions if not outright winning
positions in in a couple of the middle
games so I was surprised by the level of
his play um but but still at the end of
the day he he was the better player in
the match so uh he he did win which I
think everyone expected expected Magnus
to be a clear favorite and
things definitely didn't go too smooth
for him you know I mean the way things
transpired of course was bizarre and
performances by both players before
leading to the match I thought that
Magnus Carlson will win relatively
comfortably but uh you know as it turned
out it was uh almost the other way
around as he he was even trailing the
match at one point I would say that he
got it but not in the way I expected uh
I expected him to uh you know keep a
tight score but not by Saving these
games three and four and so on it was it
was exciting because the score was
always exciting there were really
moments when I thought that he's not
going to win so yeah I didn't expect
that to happen I was expecting both
players to be playing well and uh well
let's be honest it was not the case yeah
I think that both of them they played
below the average level I actually
thought the rapid games were really
pretty high quality when you think
there's so much at stake so much fatigue
so much tension I thought they were
really impressive but the match itself
there were some games that were very
exciting but a lot of them were a bit uh
bit of a damp squ on unfortunately
there's been some controversy about how
rapid chess decided the world
championship do you think that rapid is
a good way to decide who's the best
player well I mean I think you have to
have uh you have to have someone who
wins and uh unfortunately I think if you
keep it as classical there there is a
pretty high chance there going to be a
lot lot more draws just because it's
going to be 14 games or 16 games doesn't
mean the tie is going to be broken and
so I don't see the point uh you have to
have a way to break a tie uh that is by
nature the second option ideally you
prefer it to be decided in the regular
games and uh I don't have a problem with
it at all I think that's fine I mean if
for 12 rounds people come determined you
have to break the ti somehow and uh more
classical games that's just uh too much
maybe for the next World Championship
Match maybe they could change the rule a
little bit because to to decide the
classical world champion ion title based
on rapid games doesn't sound right no I
actually don't think I would change
anything like that and you know it was
really exciting the rapid tie breaks and
we saw some really impressive chess I
think that most people probably found
the last day of the world championship
the most
exciting uh at least I did I mean I
watched it closely and I I thought it
was a thrilling tiebreak it could have
been even it was relatively one-sided so
if it had been closer it could have been
even more exciting I think still like
four games of Rapid it's a serious much
I mean so I I don't have anything
against it but I think we should really
exclude blit if possible because blit is
something you know very very different
uh well you you got to end the thing
that's I mean we we gave them a chance
12 12 classical games a lot of games I
mean let's not kid ourselves okay 24 is
more but 12 games is a lot of games I
mean here we're going to play nine uh
it's going to be a lot going to be tired
12 games is a lot of games so you have
you have a chance to prove that you're
better if you cannot prove okay you
either play play Forever or okay you
just uh speed things
up well a very interesting point of
views from the players I found I find
the the conversation fascinating I've
done a great deal of thinking about it
and I think I have stronger views than
the players uh to me we have three
disciplines classical rapid and Blitz
and they shouldn't pollute one another
let's put it that way I don't like the
tiebreakers whatsoever so imagine you
and I were playing a blitz match
a 10 game Blitz match in the afternoon
for the championship of the club okay
Tanya and we finished by five tie well
let's use a tiebreaker let's play two
classical games to determine who's the
blitz Champion doesn't make any sense to
me you're doing it in reverse from the
world championship match and I suggested
something else it's all on chess Bas but
I really do have issues with the whole
cycle let me just throw out another
thing the
penultimate uh tournament in the cycle
is the candidates it's 14 rounds have
you ever seen a championship that is
shorter than the penultimate like if you
play snooker for example frames get
longer and longer as you go into the
world championship matches right so
you're playing 12 uh classical games in
the world championship 14 in the
candidates and the candidates is the
only tournament in the entire cycle that
doesn't use tie breaks H like
something's wrong with the world
championship cycle I'm sorry I find it
uh very illogical no I yes definitely
there are so many suggest suggestions
and options but I think with the format
that that does exist right now I do
believe that 12 games is a good number
for a classical game and using tie
breaks I think that's part of so many
sports of course it is I mean you see in
football you've got extra time you
when things do not get finalized exactly
you have to decide at some point and by
the end of it rapid and Blitz is also
chess it's not like you're going into a
tiebreaker that has nothing to do with
the spots right and you can't really
extend I mean either you say from the
beginning that there're going to be more
number of classical games but if if the
match is not decided in a certain time
frame you have to kind of give you have
to change something in the format to
make it a little more exciting quicker
that was my proposal was to play first
of all a longer match let's say 15 games
an odd number of games now why the odd
number of games so at the opening
ceremony you have the drawing of lots
you don't give the world champion the
extra black and draw odds but I'm saying
at the opening ceremony you have white
in the first and last game okay and the
player who
uh gets the extra black has draw odds so
in other words at the very start of the
match somebody's behind and throughout
the entire match whoever's trailing has
to win tame draws brings the leader of
the match closer to Victory so I was
offering as a suggestion an odd number
of games but that way it's all classical
right let's go to London and
Maurice yeah Yer I can't disagree more I
think that way the format is it's just
it's just great as a matter of fact you
know people saw this match between
Carlson and kaken and they thought oh no
it's too boring you know they played 12
games it wasn't that interesting and
then you have to go to Rapid but they
forget the there were a lot of 12 game
matches that were thrilling I mean there
were seven of these that have been
played so far over half of them had four
or more wins in the classical portion of
the event you can remember Anan doing
tremendously well against crnic uh
certainly Carson dominating Anan these
have been interesting matches you can't
just go you like institutional Amnesia
forgetting that there have been exciting
matches there also if you look at the
classical portions there have been a lot
of classical matches it's just been too
long people just get getting crushed
early on uh I I don't want to mention
this here in London too loudly but uh
Kasparov beating short I mean that was
just a a beat down uh certainly we were
happy to be like throwing the towel
pretty quickly not to watch any more of
those and it's just dragged on at the
end quite frankly when I asked the
players nine out of 10 players said this
system 12 plus Rapids is just fine
that's nine out of the 10 players
playing in this event and these are the
elite players in the world the feeling
that classical the world championship is
the world championship if you can decide
it in the 12 classical games no problem
they're very good at rapid and as you
saw Carlson played one of the most
beautiful moves in the history of the
world championship by playing the move
move Queen to 86 a brilliant finish so
you know the better player wins anyway
very good Maurice uh thank you for that
and I what can I say it's very hard to
argue in nine out of the 10 players in
the I have to go with majority but hold
on hold on why did I raise the issue of
this a problem it was gain 12 in the
35-minute punch uh essentially chess was
set up for this dramatic final game
everything's on the line one game to go
tied up U Magnus Carlson with white will
he press his opening Advantage no The
Whole World's watching and it was an
incredible dud and I thought to myself
oh that just can't happen it's terrible
for TV it's terrible for the game when
something like that happens obviously
Maurice is Right seven times they've
used this format four out of the seven
it's worked brilliantly and but that
game 12 was terrible talking about the
game 12 that was so much said about it
and of course from a spectator's point
of view completely get it it was it was
a disastrous game but then at that point
in the world championship I actually
think it was a brilliant strategic
decision by Magnus gson of course I mean
there was so much psychology at play at
that point which obviously we as
Spectators don't necessarily understand
I mean the guy clearly got three working
days for the tie breaks while Sergey
karakin had to think about defending
with black in Game 12 Magnus already
knew he was taking it to tie bre in game
11 that he was taking it in tie breaks
that is a huge advantage in that
situation right no he did the
professional thing I'm just saying how
did it reflect on chess broadly
absolutely but then he's I mean he
doesn't care about that he wants to be
world champion I mean You' got to win
yes well well we've got another update
from London with
Maurice well I'll just continue that
point yes I completely agree with you
Game 12 was absolutely a dud certainly
smart on magnus's part to take a quick
draw knowing that he wanted to take a
draw a lot of tension was in kakin was
on kakin not knowing what Magnus was
going to do so that really worked out in
magnus's favor you know I hate draw so
to to see that happen actually I was at
home I live in Brooklyn New York and I'm
only a 12 minute ride away from where
they played uh the match and I was
getting ready you know I figured okay I
don't need to come for the opening it'll
take a little while uh ju I'll just turn
it on just to see what's going on and
then within 25 minutes I was like okay I
I guess I'm not going because it was
drawn so quickly like 31 minute draw
that is certainly horrible for the fans
and something needs to be done about
that I can't imagine the people who
played $150 and took a day off uh to to
go to the match only to have a 31 move
draw so something certainly needs to be
done in that respect of course for the
players they're just trying to win the
match that's all that matters to them
but clearly there should be some
tweaking in order to to make sure that
those kind of things don't happen with
the whole world watching exactly uh
Alejandra I want to take it to you boy
we've got some really really uh
double-edged games going on this game
between Vladimir CR first of all you're
going to hear my
opinion no we've been waiting and and I
agree with you in some ways that rapid
uh tie breaks do tarnish a a little bit
of the classical chess I do see the
players point that you have to break the
tie somehow I think 12 games is more
than enough I think that anything longer
than 12 games is way too long this match
was way too long two games and then a
rest day two games and a rest day it was
way too long but my point is classical
chess is too important the world
championship right now is way too
important I think that there's an entire
cycle that people are playing that takes
forever to determine a Challenger that
lasts a match it's so like 3 weeks it
takes up too much of the calendar it's I
don't see why it's that important the
price f is out of the world compared to
other types of tournaments I don't see
why I don't see why this classical world
championship match is so important yes I
get it it should be the most important
thing we have in chess but right now it
has such a distance compared to any
other tournament any other tour compared
to any rapid even the rapid World
blessing Championship is basically a
joke compared to the classical Chess
World Championship there's not even a
process it's an open tournament I mean I
think we need to start saying hey there
are different types of Chess let's give
them their own
space and take it from there I think
classical should be decided by classical
and I think that the rapid World Blitz
champ the question is what if it's not
you've got 12 games and then you've got
six six you I think I think there's many
proposals just choose one of them uh
yaser had the idea uh that I think is
perfectly viable some people people
suggested that you know the idea that
you don't like the the world champion
retains the title which I don't
personally like some people like that
the world champion gets uh basically
like an Armageddon game at the end where
he gets to choose the color if they're
still tied it's still a classical but he
starts with last time Andro odds
whatever pick one they're not that
terrible they're not that different as
the players said and I think their main
point was that you need to break the
tide they didn't say that the rapid was
the only and best solution they said you
need to break break the tie they found
that rapid was perfectly acceptable
answer to that and I think it's just one
of the many ways that you could
Implement something if you don't like
rapid for classical chest and just
change it I mean there's a million
Solutions what I'm saying is that rapid
also should be deserving of some
important place in the Chess World and
right now it's not well I think that
rapid is actually a great way to to
break the tie breaks but we can go on
talking about this but I think we should
get back to our gam we we do in fact
have some very excited the caruana toal
off game that's exploded uh both
Vladimir and leavon seem to be mauling
one another's Kings uh vish's games
heated up uh Alejandro uh where would
you like to take
us well first let's take a look at the
game between Vladimir karnick and leevon
aronian that I have up on the screen
here we have the move Queen takes F3 and
now it's kramnick thinking he has a
couple of options I'm going to go
through them real quickly the first one
is the apparent lack of uh Queen trade
here with Queen D2 you think there's
okay you're sidest stepping the trade
I'm not threading Queen G5 because of
Queen G2 Checkmate but if black really
really wants to he trades Queens anyways
Queen G2 check is perfectly playable as
after takes takes you can take on G2 but
it doesn't actually net you a bishop
because at the end Rook C2 check
recovers that uh piece and it will be
black that's a little bit ahead you
first have to take on on G7 however this
position is probably a little dangerous
for black you can see that now with both
Kings being relatively Sav by the lack
of Queens the pawn and G7 will be a real
big problem in the long term so Queen D2
something to consider the computers are
liking to play Rook C6 to eliminate this
Rook on D6 but that seems like a little
bit of a strange move to come up with uh
so Queen D2 definitely on the cards I
was mentioning the move Rook takes D6
and I'm going to explain it now but
definitely playable the idea is that if
you take on E6 Queen takes E6 is simply
winning Rook F7 drops The Rook on C8
while if you play King h8 well I simply
Checkmate you here F takes G7 so you
cannot take The Rook you could take the
queen but after Rook six takes E2 I have
a double attack on this bishop and the
pawn on G7 again a little bit of an
advantage for white so Rook takes C6 has
to probably be met with the move
G6 again a little counterintuitive
because you're weakening your dark
sports but the point is that I'm
guaranteeing a queen trade so I'm not
really that scared this could go either
way the pawn on B6 is hanging but white
still has to be careful about some
tricks very double-edged position and I
think karnick is taking a sweet time
here calculating on which one is the
most precise continuation as we see he
does have options in this position not
an easy position to play I have to say
for a human there's a lot to consider
and you are always worried when you have
such complex weakness of color here
black on the dark squares white on the
light squares that you don't blunder
something because it's super easy to
blunder some kind of Checkmate some kind
of trick it's very easy to miss these
kind of things I think this is one of
the hardest positions and chest to
properly evaluate at some moment you
just stop and say you you you make a
judgment call is this position good for
me or bad for me and when two players uh
like a mirror reflecting I'm dominating
on the dark squares you're dominating on
the light squares how do I judge that my
domination is superior to yours I mean
it's very very hard to do and uh this
position well all three results are
possible another crazy crazy position
that's really explo exploded is this
French defense game between vesselin and
Fabiano uh vessel's Knight on A3 is
definitely stranded but look at the
trumps that he's got on the other side
of the board he's got this Rook on G7
Pawn on G6 a lot of players are could
easily ask the question how did your
Rook get there I mean like like what did
you just magically transported from H1
to G7 White's got the two Bishops but
look at this very nice imposing uh
Center by the way there's a rook f8 be
careful F2 is potentially weak black
king is much safer at the moment so
again the imbalances in this position
make it really hard to come up with a
judgment who stands better in white yes
don't forget white also has that pawn on
G6 and that's a passer and that's a
passer I mean and you go G7 I mean it I
I'm loving this position it is it's one
of those positions that are just
dynamically B bed you know I mean I hate
it when the computers come out with
double triple zeros to describe
surprised if this is the evaluation of
such a position shocked if the computer
says it's z0 simply because white has so
many trumps and as does black as does
black so that's a double-edged position
uh there was one and the vishy game by
the way I think uh he played it very
well this is the uh game between Anish
and Hikaru things very quieted down it
looks like a very nice Hedgehog with a
knight on E8 so you're supporting the D6
where I don't see big problems here for
Hikaru I think the bishop on A6 I mean
like he it's it's not the greatest
Bishop that is just white pieces are
just better place but yeah I mean to
find a weakness to break through it's um
it's going to be a big fight to be able
to do that and I think Mickey has very
much stabilized the position against
Wesley
Wesley one of our tournament leaders
Wesley has the two Bishops but the split
pawns on the queen side and the when at
at some point in the near future
Mickey's going to play the move Bishop
E5 asking white the question how are you
going to keep your two Bishops and the
structure very very solid for Mickey I
think that uh is a wellplayed game on it
way to aw doing absolutely fine in this
position exchanging the Rooks is is a
great idea because in this position with
with two Bishops I mean uh very hard to
imagine white getting anything the pawns
on A5 b67 just everything's protected
exactly and then this double another
crazy Donnie Brook going on here between
mvl vishy and mvl um vishy pawned to the
good we left the position about the move
Queen C7 Bishop F4 was played by vishy
Queen B6 Bishop E5
reinforcing this Knight on C3 and by the
way uh eyeballing this Knight on F6 G5
maybe a I love these
double uh I you know these moves where
you have a double idea behind them this
defensive offensive move Bishop E5 well
obviously is not in a position where he
can just sit and wait I mean he's less a
pawn he's got to do something and A4 I
love it because he has to open uh the
attack against the king but is this
working what is uh I
suppose the pa the key question to be
asked is what do you do if I take the
pawn because my knight is pinned let's
not forget that yes every Knight takes
A5 I mean white will jump all over take
yeah Queen B6 Knight B6 all over the
opportunity to trade Queens if white
could trade off Queens it's game over so
can I go Bishop H3 here Bishop H or it's
nothing after Knight B5 yeah that was
the idea behind vish's Bishop E5 that um
defensive uh covering the B2 Square
blocking off so unfortunately for mvl
Bishop
A3
um well now I'm really thinking holy cow
what is going on does he how is he going
to intend tend to meet this so what if I
just go Queen A5 oh no my knight on F6
comro it's sharp what's going on you're
you're thinking to hards play Simple
chess once hanging you take it in this
position after A4 Pawn takes A4 you can
take on C3 and take on D5 and then you
take on D5 and you can see the knights
are starting to swarm here on the queen
side after Bishop D4 for example the
move Queen B4 I think is key targeting
this Pawn on A4 allowing it to take with
the Knight and not trading the queens
and already white has to be a little bit
careful notice that there are threats of
Knight C3 check in certain positions so
the bishop can't really abandon the
diagonal computer thinks Queen G3 is
basically the only move if this happens
and after Queen G3 Queen takes A4 the
idea is to bring the queen to the the
defense to A3 say I really need to trade
these guys takes takes and we see the
black has recovered the pawn but this
Pawn on e4 is extremely weak it still
likes white a little bit but it does say
that he has lost quite a bit of its
Advantage you can see that the shattered
Pawn structure is going to be an issue
the Knight can jump to F4 and maybe
capture this one on H3 in exchange for
the one on e4 yes a little better for
white you have the pair of Bishops and
obviously uh taking on H3 is not going
to be such a big deal for white who may
even welcome the opening of the H file
but it's not as clear as it was before
uh on another crazy game actually the
computers didn't like this move E4 by
Fabiano Karan after H takes G6 they
really wanted to take control of the
file and very brutally threaten
checkmate with rook hf8 and here
probably the only way of Defending
that's concrete is Rook F7 after which
the computer say okay I don't really
care about you having a Pawn on the
seventh rank the idea is that I'm going
to start transferring the pieces to the
side of the board so Queen E7 attacks
this pawn bishop H5 and then Queen E7
with this really nice maneuver either
Queen H4 or queen E6 uh targeting things
on the king side taking advantage of the
fact that white is currently very much
on the queen side not really in time to
transfer his pieces to the defense of
the king he thinks black is just a
little bit better in this position after
E4 the computer like to Simply play Rook
F7 right away and now G7 is actually
something you have to contend with
notice that the also The Rook is hanging
to the bishop so not really clear to me
what Fab is planning on doing against
the simple move Rook F7 and then follow
it up with D7 you would like to play D4
at some point but you have to watch out
for Knight C4 you have to watch out for
taking and leaving the E4 Pawn a little
bit vulnerable what I'm most curious
about is what exactly was the point of
playing E4 because you're opening up the
bishop but I'm not entirely sure what
you're opening it up for you can go
Knight E5 but you cannot do it
immediately so it's a little bit
baffling to me that he played E4 I'm
trying to understand the move even
though it's probably not such a bad move
at all I'm not really getting the point
gotcha and we have Maurice Ashley in
London well he'll be joining us pretty
soon but it is quite interesting what
you say about this position and I'm not
sure how Fabiano is going to handle this
problem of now Rook F7 and and the idea
of G7 I I guess he's going to have to
play Rook f8 nonetheless and I go Bishop
G7 now well let's bring that up just uh
because it oh it's such an interesting
position I mean E4 is quite surprising
because you're always fa game you're
always thinking about this bishop on C3
and you know sometimes you want to play
E4 you're not sure so E4 is so committal
yeah and again Rook f8 was very
suggestive uh brutal as as Alejandra put
it and now Rook F7 and again uh just uh
covering the
file uh I think Rook f8 because with a
move like D4 you're always worried about
Knight C4 jumps at some point right
precisely but well we're going to get
back to this game we've got Maurice with
a
guest I am with Grandmaster Chris Ward a
former British champion author of some
very well-known books certainly ones on
the dragon that have have been sold on
eBay now apparently they're on eBay for
hundreds of dollars is what I hear okay
maybe it's only I can't afford them
myself yeah you can't even afford to get
your own books Chris is one of the
commentators along with Grand Master
Lawrence Tren and apparently you're the
one who started Lawrence down the
decadent path of salsa dancing well
that's true yeah I told him everything
he knows and uh yes yes let's just say
if everyone anyone want to dance with
Lawrence uh not people here are in the
audience right now but yes any young
ladies out there want to give it a go
and guys I tell you it's a fantastic
chess and salsa I play chess people
don't believe I do salsa dancing I do
salsa dancing people definitely don't
believe I play chess I can tell you that
well Lawrence is the one who's got me
going down the path as well so you're my
grandfather in some
ways people might not believe that
indeed well this tournament has
certainly seeing its fancy moves uh this
this particular round we've seen some
excitement this one here the game
between CR and aroni and what are your
thoughts as this has progressed we see
this check occurred on this square and
takes and now an Intero and we have this
as the current position yeah I mean I
have to say this game I mean this has
just been such a fantastic refreshing
tour after the world championship has
been a lot of deta people little bit
boring some but this nothing boring
about this what even this game early on
you yourself said well this game boring
English blah blah this has come sprung
to life and what was particularly
interesting here I know there's a bishop
on G2 there's a Pawn on G7 but if you
only went back just a few moves
beforehand we had if we we traveled back
to yeah I mean this was unbelievable
this position lot of firor so in fact we
mentioned what black would just love to
just switch that bishop and queen the
other direction switch them around
Checkmate there and we what we've
actually got is we've got white seemly
trying to give Checkmate here on G7 and
black trying to give Checkmate on G2 how
often does that happen people think yeah
I attack on the king side you attack on
the queen side but no both sides Going
Hammer on Tom on the king side here um
and we were hoping obviously we're
hoping for a Checkmate but in fact it
didn't quite transpose that way white
yeah they kind of see those things they
kind of notice checkm yeah you know but
of course White had the idea of Queen to
G4 coming T now though it looks more
like an end game and we have a different
type of dynamic in particular here black
would love to occupy the seventh rank
with draw that Bishop get some checks
over here why on the other hand we're
now closer to why would love to snuffle
that Pawn here on B6 opposite color
Bishops of course everyone says oh
they're always drawing the not with
Rooks on the board and not with this
massive Pawn still here on G7 so still
everything to go here white needs to be
very careful about his second rank here
but of course he's got that extra that
massive Pawn there on G7 black of course
never going to be able to leave the back
rank complete a rook DH certainly a lot
Happening Here for sure let's go to some
games that that are full of more content
as a matter of fact this one we thought
Anan was just going to roll over over
mvl but somehow that night off genius
he's figured out a way to complicate
things and it's not as easy as it was
absolutely right if we go back to the
move Queen F2 just a few moves back here
yeah Queen F2 now after the move Queen
F2 which I think was a good move by
white of course pinning this Knight on
B6 here uh on C5 to the queen on B6 and
there was a long thought about this
particular move here and the problem is
black wants to be able to play this move
A4 let's not forget he is a whole Pawn
down and he would love to get out that
white king but can't play this move Pawn
up to A4 at the moment because after the
complications of Knight takes pawn and
the queen swapping off the bishop would
hang on B4 but something very crafty
happens here because move on a few more
moves here and we get the same scenario
but with the bishop actually on E5 just
before he plays A4 here and of course
now he can play A4 so finally we're
seeing black get some excitement Maxim's
probably oh you know I sacrificed that
pawn he could have done that Rook takes
C3 I would have done Rook takes C3 long
timeo long time ago but we can't go back
to things all right well let's jump we
see Michael Adams has stabilized the
position have let's go to this one
though that's also for oh my word and do
you know the other thing which is
absolutely amazing I'm sure anybody
following home any club player the most
refreshing thing about this whole T
isn't even just the fact that we're
getting exciting games it's not even the
fact that there's blunders and
everyone's human we can all blunder
things but it's the fact that we seen so
many different chess openings that's we
people are sing they're going oh we
never see the French defense anymore
more at top level chess i' played the
French defense we do today we've seen
the Sicilian what other openings may we
still yet get well we've got the French
defense here and I have to say if we go
back again just a couple more moves here
um yeah just before the The Rook on the
seventh rank so when the right Rook
that's it around about this stage here
and things were starting to live we were
actually in the audience quite liking
Black's position around here um plow on
a few moves The Rook gets to the G G7
and the White Rock is brilliant on the
seventh fret normally but it's on its
own is no support these other white
pieces not really helping out here so
black now E5 wonderful gets the Pawns in
the middle of the ball we got a few more
moves and look at that fantastic
fantastic porn Center here however
decisions have to be made you know it's
all very well sitting there going I got
two Pawns in the middle of the board I
would love to get some action here I
would love to get some action on that F2
Square rook f8 and of course the chck
mayate through but he has to make a
decision does he put the pawn onto the
black square but then the light Square
Bishop there might be a bind there might
be a BL eight so of course he went for
E4 and actually wow don't you know it a
few moves later Rook FM out the way of
that past Pawn yeah let's not forget how
many more pawns are we going to get on
G7 in this particular tournament that is
protected by Bish that is awesome so
even though you look at the Knight on A3
what's that doing what's this Rook doing
and you look at those wonderful black
pawns here we must not forget that Rook
on the seventh ring guarding F2 Pawn on
G7 and things could easily go horribly
wrong for fabul who unfortunately fappy
has left himself pretty short on time no
increments in this tournament here he's
going to have to sit there think think
think and he could well regret getting
social on time indeed you can see that
Chris is very bored watching chess uh
all the time certainly it's old fight
Grandmaster Chris Ward entertaining the
crowd here with Lawrence Tren they make
quite a team I'm often distracted
watching the two of them here and the
audience absolutely loves listening we
have a packed house here at the London
chess classic thank you Maurice and
thank you Chris Ward I have never been
exposed to his enthusiasm his new unique
brand well things are really heating up
we're going to take a very super shot
break and be right
[Music]
back I'm Mike maeni manager of the
Cardinals in chess fanatic at the
world-renowned chess club and
Scholastics C Center of St Louis across
from the World Chess Hall of Fame St
Louis status as the chess capital of the
nation is on Full display with a
welcoming environment and Scholastic
outreach program that works with over a
100 Schools our goal is to teach play
and promote the sport so whether you've
played for years or never before we
invite you to experience all chess has
to
offer
[Music]
n
oh
[Music]
n
hello and welcome back and we do have a
first result of round two with cnick and
Lavon
aronian signing for peace signing the
peace agreement with two co-leaders we
actually have three players in first
after the first round and in the final
position Bishops of opposite color I
thought Vladimir still had something
Alejandro is convincing me that it
wasn't the case and the draw was a
proper result an exciting game that
suddenly fizzled yes a a game which had
the possibility of either sides being
Che at any point and then we had a big
decision in the game uh between via
Anand and mvl after Knight takes D5 we
were looking at the possibility of
Bishop D4 Queen A5 Queen to G3 Queen
takes A4 and queen A3 A variation that
was computer generated but a very human
decision in my view Rook takes D5
Exchange sacrifices incredibly common in
the Sicilian and after Rook takes D5 uh
Bishop takes E4 Rook B6 and A5 so white
has the two Bishops very powerful two
Bishops very very this bishop on C3
especially that's a star in the position
as it's eyeballing the G7 Pawn so a
double-edged position going on here
between uh the she and mvl but I am not
very convinced about the exchange sacrif
I mean I'm not sure if it was required
at that point because I just thought
that Wishy was doing so well and I don't
know if this sacrifice adds to his
Advantage for example after a move like
A5 if I just move my queen to B5 looks
looks like a good Square looks like a
good Square absolutely and you're
looking at Knight takes E4 and Rook
takes C3 types of idea exactly okay so
let's see at some point yes you have to
start pushing those pawns you know well
I'm indeed I'm looking at uh sacrifices
based on Bishop G7 and F6 they certainly
not working at this moment I like my I
like my Bishops as well
um I'm just uh how about to move like
Queen F4 here Queen F4 I'm I'm not happy
about Knight takes E4 You Queen E4 yeah
and I'm well at some point you're just
going to go F6 and uh there's a rook C3
in the position that I would like to
preserve the bishop if it all possible
I'm worried of course about Knight A4 as
being um tricky uh the way I would
preserve my Bishop by the way would be
to play Bishop G2 and Bishop F1 and we
talked about the Bobby fiser Bishop on
C4 I'd love to reroute it to that square
um so Knight A4 now this is the problem
is the counterplay I definitely have to
be conscious the counterplay Knight A4
Bishop E5 you even have such funky moves
like Rook A3
which are upsetting to say the lead yeah
or Rook E8 because the B2 is is you
can't take my Rook on D6 exactly I'm all
kind of gummed up my point is yes that I
just I'm not convinced if at that moment
where he took Rook D5 if that was really
required because I thought white was
doing quite well I
mean I think as move Queen F2 slip
really we could have almost had exactly
the same position with the pawn on G5
which would have been very much more
meaningful uh when the pawn was on G5 I
think this was a a how do you say a
human decision where you where you think
you're uh more than enough compensation
defitely yeah and you've you've taken
some of the heat off uh by eliminating
that Knight on D5 now the question is is
after A5 Queen B5 has vishy misjudged
the position that this move Knight A4
Knight E4 gaining uh black in this case
too much counter plight I think it's the
case let me get some reassurance uh from
Ali hondro here has vishy spoiled his
position
alandro yes sir the computers are not
very happy about what he's done honestly
they didn't like sacrificing The
Exchange that much but you can
understand it's a very human decision to
go for this because because now there is
really not that much risk even though
perhaps his Advantage has diminished in
a sense he's not getting mated in any V
variation and that's somewhat comforting
when you're a human being in this case
after the move Queen B5 which we do have
on the board Queen E2 Queen E2 seems to
be like the only real try you absolutely
have to trade Queens as black takes Rook
takes and now the the interesting thing
is to evaluate the end game the end game
is obviously favoring white you have
just a slightly more material the bishop
with the two pawns Bishop on C3 is
obviously very well placed the thing is
that the Rooks are very active and in an
open position they can really cause a
lot of problems after just taking on e4
you don't really want to allow the two
Bishops to survive Rook takes C4 even a
move like Rook dc6 it's really hard for
white to make any progress eventually
this Pawn is going to come to F6 I'm
going to put the King on F7 and it
there's just not that much to do
remember that any trade of Rooks here
will be favoring black but it's
difficult for the this Rook to get
active without black trying to threaten
some kind of Rook trade you also have to
worried about Rook H6 taking this Pawn
in some cases Alejandra couldn't black
have just gone Rook E8 in that position
where you took Knight E4 I think
strategically it's a mistake to play
Rook E8 because then you're playing this
kind of end game and in this kind of end
game I actually do think that white has
chances because the pair of Bishops is
very very powerful unless you can get
one of my Bishops immediately then I can
start coordinating my Bishops and start
pushing the queen side pawns whereas
black doesn't have much of a concrete
idea the Knight on C5 we've talked about
this over and over needs an anchor it
doesn't have an anchor in the entire
board so so it the knight's going to be
pushed around very easily after Knight
E4 Bishop E1 I think that only white can
win this end game even though perhaps
with Perfect Defense to draw I think
it's very very pleasant for white
whereas I think Knight takes C4 just
eliminate the bishop with your knight
gives Maxim excellent chances to hold a
position and it's probably going to
happen because we do have Queen E2 on
the board and I really do think that
after this this you either take on e4
immediately maybe you play Rook D1 check
first but that Bishop has to go right
well we do have a big update on the
carwan board yeah that uh position has
just exploded uh we left it more or less
about these parts with a sharp tactical
tactics in view Alejandra take it away
uh who stands better in why well let's
go back to this position we were talking
about the move Rook F7 hitting the Rook
this is where we left off more or less
after Rook H G8 G7 K play this move King
E7 which kind of shows you're in time
pressure just kind of trying to make a
move that's a little prophylactic moving
the king out of the way Queen takes H6
kapal said hey that that that's a point
one I'll take it Knight D3 was played
not something the computers approve of
Bishop takes D3 obviously protecting
against the checkm threat takes and this
nice move rookie one and it seems that
Fabiano karon is in a world of trouble
at least according to the computers of
course it's still a very double-edged
position but unfortunately for him this
Pawn on G7 is really killing any type of
counterplay he wants to achieve the
Rooks cannot get in the game you cannot
put pressure on the king even though the
Knight is misplaced considerably there's
really nothing much that white black can
do about it because you cannot
coordinate the pieces against the king
this spawn on D3 it's not really going
anywhere the computer's already
suggested to play D2 and Fabiano is in a
terrible time situation I would like to
get a closeup on his clock if we can at
some point to get the exact time that he
has looking at the position tactically
it's already very dangerous for him I
think that the brightness is uh not
really allowing us to see it but if we
go back to the board and we see start
analyzing some of the ideas here in this
position take a look at for example
something like 95 cannot play because of
Bishop takes E5 but then how do you get
the knight in the game this is the
reason the computers are suggesting the
move D2 so that you uh move the bishop
out of the way in order to get the
knight in but look at how easily Black's
position can fall apart now you cannot
take on D2 with the queen because D4
suddenly this bishop is trapped kind of
a funny way to trapping the bishop you
have to take with the Queen the bishop
but that's good enough after Knight E5
something even like Rook takes E5 Bishop
takes E5 I really like this move Bishop
B3 very important to allow the Knight to
come in the game if you play D4 because
I trade queens and then go Knight
C4 if Bishop D4 then takes takes on B6
takes some uh Knight C2 here this end
game looks almost winning for the white
side the pawn of G7 is just way too
strong nothing black can really do about
it these are the kind of things that he
has to be very worried about so if the
rookie won the challenge is first of all
try to find a move for black which is
not easy when you're in time pressure
and especially in such a sharp position
where you're trying to create something
concrete and second I just think that uh
technically he really is kind of busted
I PA on G7 is just too powerful yeah the
pawn on G7 is huge and he has played the
move Bishop C5 just bring that update uh
does that change matters not too much
here uh topalov has several choices he
has plenty of time to figure one of them
out uh technically Kon doesn't have a
threat I mean Bishop C5 didn't actually
create very much because the bishop
cannot take on F2 as it's defended by
The Rook so the computer simply want to
play hey Queen G6 and then take on D3 on
the next move eliminate this powerful
pawn and slowly build up your advantage
now the black has no counterplay so
Bishop C5 is just a move that doesn't
really help lack that much I see uh by
the way just to remind the audience that
our time control does not include the
increment and therefore why the time
trouble for this first time control of 4
yes uh is important as uh if Fab's in
ser I time control serious time pressure
he's not getting that 30C bonus actually
we've been noticing Fabiano having a lot
of trouble with the clock off late in
general he does seem to be on the on the
lower side of the clock in many of his
games and he's been struggling to keep
his time under good control and also
what we've been seeing a lot with
vesselin I mean he plays this this
creative aggressive chess which the
computers can refute and you know it's
it's questionable from a pure computer
Compu engine point of view but it's
amazing the amount of times his
opponents go wrong well of course
because it's a it's a human struggle and
uh vesselin has this uh fantastic
ability of putting pressures on his
opponent and causing them to take their
time
Alejandro huge update in the Anan game
Tanya I'm GNA answer your question with
exactly what happened in the game why
you don't keep the two Bishops alive
huge mistake by uh mvl here playing the
move rookie eight which I think is just
absolutely terrible from a strategical
point of view I actually don't know how
2800 can play the move rookie eight
after Bishop F3 takes takes he played uh
Rook C1 which I think is just very
mediocre I think he was tactically
trying to take the pawn and Bam and
unplay the move Bishop
F3 very simple tactic for a grandmas I
know that yaser y salivating at the idea
of this move the point is that after
Brook takes C2 Bish Bishop takes B7 bam
on the board The Rook on C2 dominated by
this bishop on C3 and it is a well-known
pattern for Grand Masters that a knight
on B7 that is attacked by The Pawn on A6
cannot actually catch the pawn so this
is already completely over as the pawn
simply Queen's rookie to The Rook really
has to hurry up to the defense but if
your Pawn takes Rook E8 I have the move
Bishop E5 controlling the B8 square and
that would be game over so after the
move Rook C1 Bishop F3 it seems like the
Freshman is simply going to go down I
don't see any good reply here against
simply Bishop takes B7 on the next move
notice how dominant this Bishops are
against The Rook cannot go to D1 cannot
go to E1 it's over I I don't see any
defense here I think that Bishop takes
B7 in the next move is Just Killer
absolutely and it it I don't see any
really good move Rook takes E2 and I
think I can't even bring my Rook back to
defense from anywhere yeah Bishop takes
B7 and I think's gone Rook C2 and
Bish Bishop B7 is just screaming to be
played it's very obviously K see Maxim
is like oh my God why didn't I take the
did I do yes yeah Knight E4 had to be
played at that point well you've got to
get rid of those two Bishops especially
because of your B7 weakness Maxim listen
to me the Bishops you have to eliminate
them and he's going to lose he's just
going to lose because he didn't take on
e4 and you think about the super
majority of three versus one on the
queen side that Anand is enjoying uh
Bishop takes B7 eliminating that last
pawn and the two Bishops in an open
position it's over wow that will and and
of course is going VY of course
understands on fire yeah but he of
course he understands the position is
winning and you he's reaching for it and
you say to yourself why is he hesitating
well to be sure to be sure to be sure
that's exactly what it's all about he
just wants to be absolutely convinced
himself there's no defense and there you
have there you go Bishop Tak the funny
thing is that even even immediate
resignation immediate resignation right
uh when uh Max went for Rook C Rook D1
check to Rook C1 he must have just had
it in his mind that the C2 Pawn was uh
was falling and just Bishop F3 and then
he realized it's over but I think it's I
think it's such a bad decision not
because Bishop takes B7 was on the air
and he missed it right honestly even if
he white for some magic Bishop takes B7
does not work right this is just much
better for white you just go King A3
King B4 you march a king up looks
extremely dangerous why not take the
bishop it it was a forced decision and
it's a remarkable uh blindness there no
no explanation for it you're absolutely
right how a 2800 would not make that
decision as
shocking we have a new co-leader sudden
result on vishy mvls board just when you
thought that Maxim had everything under
control and this idea of Bishop B7
because we all know that the Knight
against this side a or H Pawn in any end
game is a complete disaster the Knight
is not able to defend it from queening
so this is a very a very basic concept
that we know from forever but for our
viewers that's a beautiful pattern very
much worth remembering because it does
happen so often in night endings yes
where you where B7 Pawn is defending an
A5 and you eliminate that B7 PA by
giving a piece for it absolutely a rook
even and then the night can't stop can't
stop the a pawn from queening and uh wow
what a what a finish by Wishy and very
disappointing for mvl Big Time result
there uh turning to our other co-leader
going into the round and our uh Grand
chest leader we have Wesley so against
Mickey Adams it was the two Bishops but
with this kind of fractured pawns over
here split pawns I should say on the
queen side when we left it we were
leaving at about these parts we haven't
paid too much attention since uh Bishop
D1 Queen C6 Bishop C2 King f8 and E4
okay by Wesley as he's trying to get in
the E4 E5 and causing some Mischief in
the position now the question is how
much Mischief is being caused if we play
a move like Bishop
C5 right so if I yes I give check and
I'll drop back with my knight uh notice
very importantly that there is no Bishop
takes G7
check because the Knight on E8 is
defended also by the queen on
C6 um do we follow it up with E5 or
perhaps Queen
D5 but I look at this position yes Queen
D5 looks like a nice way of continuing
you don't really want to trade those
queens and well I don't know you're this
Pawn on C4 was um a Target now it's
actually playing very nice role in
Bishops you've got to like the ending
for white yeah is Wesley going to
squeeze something now I played the move
Bishop uh d uh six uh well we're going
to get back to this we've got Maurice
with
Maxim we with Maxim Vash Agra who has
lost his game to vishwanathan Anan makes
seem this seem like a very sharp opening
right from the start of night off you
are a night off specialist you had to
play night off yesterday today it was
not so easy how did you feel when he was
playing all these rambunctious pawn
moves F4 G4 F5 in the opening were you
comfortable because it seemed like he
was very much in his preparation yeah
it's very typical of course uh in the
night of that you know white sponge for
over and you you need to react correctly
I probably didn't and um yeah my
position was always on the unpleasant
side I mean even if I played very
accurate moves I I think uh I I had to
suffer and you know to to be always on
the look for tricks so things didn't
transpire so so well for me and there
did seem to be a moment in the game
though like around now that you had
fought back you play this A5 A4 idea
seemed like you were back in the game
yeah I liked when I found this A5 uh
moves that you know it looks very slow
but at the same time it's not easy to to
prevent A4 but um still I mean after
this extion stck by vishi my position
was still very dubious and of course I
blundered right at the end it seems like
the engines I mean right around here
after they chain sack they they weren't
that impressed by the sacrifice it
seemed like black was okay did did you
feel under a lot of pressure while you
were in the game that this sacrifice was
overwhelming yeah of course I mean the
thing is here I mean I basically Blended
when I played this hook D1 Rook eight I
could take of course this was of course
the way to play probably but it's still
very unpleasant and uh because of the
majority on this side yes uh among
others also it's not so easy to to to
know what to do on the king side and you
know white just brings this king I don't
know maybe starts with L B4 or King A2
simply and okay maybe maybe I'm holding
but you know it seems like you know
seems like a long stretch I would say
like I take I play King B3 yeah and
certainly you know
things to far coming up in the game so
not a great result for you today how do
you bounce back going into the next
rounds yeah I mean it's never present
you know to get out prepared to and to
get out played so convincingly so you
know I need to to refocus to make use of
the Chan I will get into the next round
and uh and see how it goes I mean you
have to take it round by want from here
I do have one question for you sorry to
keep you there was a move you had in the
game Rook takes C3 much earlier uh if I
can get my screen to go back to that
position the right out of the opening he
was playing very quickly and you played
D5 yeah it was right here yeah I could
take of course but you know in this kind
of positions the luck of light squ
Bishops is f white has to play H4 but
still it's not Queen B6 was the the idea
yeah just I mean it's very possible that
this actually was what I looked at
because I'm pretty sure I looked at this
L for black and of course it's playable
and maybe it was a way to go but uh in
the game you know when you don't really
know how to respond it's not it doesn't
look so easy but yeah maybe this was a
way to play it if I was maybe maybe not
try in this position
well thanks a lot for joining us and we
hope for a better chances for you in the
rest of your games thank you Max V grav
number four player in the world taking
on the chin today but he'll be back for
the next few rounds of the London chess
class thank you Maurice and U it's
really really tough when you lose a game
and you come on and it's sort of like
you know how did it go badly you know
you know but it was very nice of mvl to
come and share his thoughts absolutely
Alejandro what's happening in that
Karana game is it's is it still topov
well Topo was blowing it that's what's
going on here after Rook E6 Rook C8 was
forced Rook E6 I didn't like I like
Queen G6 and eliminating this pawn and
here he played the move Queen G5 which I
actually don't know what purpose it
serves because even though you might
take the pawn on D5 this is not exactly
the pawn you wanted to take as it allows
the Rooks to come to the D file and
support they already passed Pawn on D3
I'm not really sure what the move Queen
G5 is about but more than that it has a
tactical issue that after Bishop takes
A3 Pawn takes A3 I have Queen B5
unpinning my Knight and threatening D2
which allows me to threaten both Knight
d8 and D2 on the next move very powerful
continuation unfortunately Kar is
running out of time and he did not find
this line this is all would have been
completely crazy after A4 Queen C4 all
these moves forced white has to find
Rook takes C6 Rook takes C6 and hope
that after Bishop D2 this is kind of
holding on this side of the board the
pawn on G7 PR some counterplay but you
can see that this is a mess and not the
clear advantage that he used to have
we're going to update you on what he did
play right after we have this interview
with vishan from
London well we are with the tiger from
Madras Vish and we saw the Clause come
out today vishy a great game on your
part first of all congratulations this
game was wild the way you blitzed out
the first few moves tell us were you
deep in your preparation up to this
point yes um in fact um the idea with
the E4 Queen E2 and long the castles and
sides um was known to me and uh the
point is of course black has very good
play but I think the process of getting
the pawn on D5 back is going to cost him
whenever he tries to resolve the tension
and take the pawn back it's not going to
it's going to be tough for him okay so
before we jump to that let's get to this
position because Julian Hudson was going
apoplectic in the VIP room talking about
the sacrifice with Rook takes C3 Pawn
takes and Knight takes on e4 saying just
it was forced it had to be done you
clearly must have seen this this
position at home what was your
assessment here if you may share those
thoughts um I will just say that I
neither the the possibility was not
unknown to me uh nor was Julian going
apoplectic unknown to me uh I'm well
aware of both so I just say that okay so
I I I thought you might have had one or
two ideas about what to do after Rook
takes R C3 is the first thing you check
so uh Rook C3 is very sharp try but U
like I said I have seen it before yes
okay okay the the political answer all
right let's jump down to the point
though when it did start to get a bit
strange right around here when he played
the move A5 uh and queen F2 here were
you still feeling very confident about
your position at this point it seemed
like somehow he had gotten just a little
bit going in the game yes I kept waiting
uh for black to be forced to resolve the
tension but uh I mean simply that this
thing explodes Bishop takes C3 Knight
takes D5 go Bishop D4 or something some
Mass exchange but uh I mean I I can see
why he doesn't do it because he's always
a pawn down at the end of it but here
after Rook
fd8 I guess it's Rook H E1 seems like a
natural enough move because there are
positions where I want to take on e4 and
I don't want to be pinned right and I
wanted to find some I mean I looked at
Rook
F1 uh G5 many moves but I couldn't find
something that I was fully happy with so
finally I went with this maybe G5 is
reasonable um I went with this thinking
again what is he going to do against A5
I mean sorry against G5 and then he came
up with A5 MH and again and again I was
not able to bend the position to my will
now in this position the engines are
talking about the move E5 uh D6 excuse
me as a key move here it's difficult for
him when when your your Bishop gets to
attack this Rook on this Square did you
did you inspect this move at all D6 it
seems
counterintuitive yes I didn't entirely
see the point after Rook takes D6 but um
so the C here and now to force him to ah
and then Knight takes E4 takt The Rook
okay I see it now
um yeah
I D6 is a deep move I wish IID found it
but
um uh so maybe this was the point but
Queen F2 looked again excellent I mean
look at the movie finds Queen C7 and we
just again repeating and this was again
very hard for me
to and what I also missed was here
G5
Knight takes
D5 yeah and Knight takes E4 Knight D3 I
couldn't make this work for
me uh I don't know if it's a slow engine
or I'm wrong but uh King A1 Queen takes
B3 and somehow I kept running into
trouble here the sharp you word about
the attack on this side of course yes
exactly Rook C1 Bishop uh
D2 uh Queen Queen D2 Knight
B4 Knight
C3 yeah this could scare anybody this
kind of line with the mating threats
potential but yeah but but it looks like
he might kind of relaxed I don't know
why I mean anyway A4 A3 was one
possibility but I didn't I didn't even
see what's happening here what is the
queen E2 winning wow May thre on the
back rank holding on the attack no that
I I kind of saw but I just felt that
black could make a pawn move but of
course he probably wants me to continue
B6 well this would have been uh good if
I had uh highly complicated line yeah
and then I lik Bishop F4 because I think
but uh he very calmly went back here and
then exactly with my Bishop on D2 I have
Knight A4 against A4 right but he is uh
got my Bishop out on the other side then
I went for
this now what was your assessment right
here and we don't have too much time
because there's time pressure happening
in other games but right here when you
took on on uh D5 did you feel that you
had a real advantage or that the game
was just transforming into a different
material imbalance I felt on a good day
I was better but um with the time and
with this pieces swarming around the
queen side I was a bit uh cautious in my
assessment what was his time pressure
here what was the situation no we I I
still had uh 20 minutes but if I it's
somehow still very tactical and if I
drift another 10 minutes suddenly you're
down to it's something like that not I
was not in serious time pressure of
course so Rook D5 was a practical
decision In This Moment well I don't see
what else I don't see what else here cuz
the bishop D4 you goes Queen
B4 and that that would have led to some
sharp things as well very complicated
game yes so but then when I saw A5 and
queen E2 I was happy because I knew that
all the end games are much better for me
even the two Bishops against the rook
and Knight is very comfortable because
it's two pawns it's not one and as Maxim
pointed out if I can put the bishop on
D4 and play C3 and B4 then I'm winning
so it's difficult for him Tommy were you
surprised when he blundered just gave
you Bishop takes B7 or just happy too
happy to be
surprised well uh it was it was clear
from his reaction he had missed it also
so yeah well how did you feel I'm asking
well I'm I'm depending on this resource
so I was kind of uh in many lines if he
goes Rook H1 and all I need Bishop F3 B7
to work so inde well congratulations on
that Victory puts you in a tie for first
are you in clear first no you're TI
sorry T first uh early tournament still
but good good start sure of course uh
I'm very
happy vishan Onan showing why he is
indeed a five-time world champion giving
a youngster a lesson today in this
assilian defense thank you well Bishop
B7 work it did but things have gotten
extremely crazy in the Karana game I
mean he missed this opportunity that he
had to take on A3 and instead he went
went with Bishop D4 right and now I'm
just looking at this position yes and
wondering can't I take on D5 Queen takes
D5 well as Alejandro was mentioning the
problem is that's not really the pawn
you want to capture because it's this
Pawn on D3 that should be frightening
you so after something like Bishop takes
C3 B takes C3 rook
d8 and now Rook D6 or Rook D7 Rook D6
let's say Rook D my on the seven
understood but now there's going to be a
queen E2 issue so Queen B2 Queen
B2 uh this is getting scary uh so I take
D guys
guys we we have a move so we we should
analyze that especially because Fabiana
corana has two minutes we have this
position on the board toala has just
played the move Rook E1 and this is
something that should go on the tactics
books oh black has the move Rook takes
G7 eliminating the pawn on this Square
you might be wondering what what's the
point of that if Bishop takes D4 I take
the queen that's clear but if Rook takes
G7 there is no defense against Rook h8
oh my God is
to in two minutes no he's not and he did
and he that's nasty and he didn't he
took on C3 takes on C3 which also a
viable uh move G7 just G him a huge
Advantage what what a tactic though rook
h8 and you cannot stop Rook H1 there is
just no way of doing it amazing tactic
uh Queen B2 is what he played yes still
very double-edged many moves to go to
move 40 he has only two minutes uh left
so we can definitely focus on that game
toal's trying to keep the pressure but
with this queen on B2 being very
annoying this Knight is very weak black
obviously got counterplay and this is
what I'm saying that theala went from a
winning position to something that is
just completely a mess right now
unbeliev in that final position that you
had on your board BTO um
Alejandro uh okay we see the move Rook
E1 uh Bishop takes E3 B takes C3 Queen
B2 I was wondering can I uh I'd love to
trade Queens yes I think uh Queen C1 you
don't have uh D2 because my king
protects E1 can I just take on A2 well
that was what I was hoping because then
I could go Queen B1 threatening
Checkmate forcing the trade and I'm
hoping that this Pawn G7 will carry uh
the day in any end game but is it over
yet because I play Queen B1 Knight
B1 getting my knight for the first time
almost since the opening back into the
game I mean no it's not over it's just a
very unclear end game materials even
it's true that the pawn on G7 is very
annoying but the Knight on B1 is still a
little p to the D3 Pawn it's itself
Annoying It's still alive that is and if
I can somehow get my knight to attack
that pawn that's that's game we do have
a move on the board he's gone and by the
way I don't know if our times are
correct but I'm looking at a minute and
30 seconds with no increment with no
increment to move 40 and they're still
and this is going to get crazy guys cuz
after Knight B1 just threatning Queen D2
here there you go Rook C8 only move in
the position it's black in the
initiative but things are not so easy so
what has happened at Knight B1 Rook C
E8 Knight B1 Rook e ooh indeed and now
now there's some stuff going on Rook
tak8 is possible surprisingly really
Rook tak8 is actually the top move of
the computer but it gets very wild Rook
takes C8 Rook takes C8 and it just wants
to play like a computer G3 G3 just to
get out of the Checkmate inviting a
capture of a piece with a check King G2
and of course everybody's favorite
computer
evaluation Z after something like D2 I
suspect uh it wants to take on A2 so
that's simply wants to take on A2 that's
a good question what is going on after
D2 D2 I queen takes D2 I'm supposed oh
right Queen D2 just but then Queen G6
and I thought that was how you're going
to get5 right but now I'm whoa I'm going
Rook f8 there could be Four Queens
appearing on the board here uh this is a
crazy position yeah D2 Queen takes D2 is
winning for white D2 Queen takes D2 is
winning for white yeah because I was
thinking Rook takes E8 not at this point
think before Queen yes yeah over here D2
doesn't work because white just simply
takes the pawn You Queen G6 you have
Rook f8 yes got it got it that's very
important D2 Queen takes D2 Queen
G6 uh Rook f8 so now our viewers up to
date with our problem the pawn on G7 is
just huge is the problem yeah so so
after Rook E8 but he has also other
options I mean I think the more human
move is to just play Queen D2 honestly
yes I think a lot of us would just say
okay I got to block the pawn on D2 and
save my knight on B1 and then again
black has choices you can take on E one
yes or you can play a cheeky move Queen
C2 Queen C2 that is
cheeky oh still a crazy game with all
three results all three results possible
very very very
complicated and we have an update in the
game between Wesley so our tournament
leader versus Mickey Adams and
apparently Wesley is pulling out the
stubs uh I will turn it over to you
alandro as I find the game onl guys we
left it off here in this position after
the move Queen D5 Queen G6 was played
you were considering Queen takes D5 uh
Adams decided not to exchange the Queens
but after Queen G6 well some Quiet Moves
King G7 King E7 decided okay let's push
my pawns let's augment the power of this
Bishops at for is very logical and L C6
to much a little weakening but okay it's
not a terrible move Queen D3 Knight went
to C7 already a blunder and this is the
point that after F5 the queen has no
good squares it has to retreat to H7
which is obviously not what Adams wanted
to do he wanted to put it on G5 but
there's a huge move here in this
position if s plays the move Bishop E5
I'm going to have to ask you how do you
defend this Knight right and the Queen
might get trapped too that's the big
problem if the Knight Retreats on E8
Bishop F4 traps the queen if Queen H5
Bishop D1 simply attacks the queen and
it's game over and if the queen goes to
F6 then E5 traps the queen and it's game
over so after Bishop E5 that's that's
game you cannot actually defend the
Knight you would like to play Knight E6
Pawn takes but you don't have time to
take my Bishop because of Queen D7 Queen
takes F7 Checkmate uh very soon so you
have to take on E6 which is just
resigning you might as well resign
because just down a piece so Bishop E5
is completely winning a very easy move
for Wesley to F honestly because while
you're you're attacking the horsey and
he's gone Bishop E5 and he yeah he goes
Bishop B5 and Adams can resign very
similar to yesterday's game in time
pressure Adams goes from a almost equal
position to blundering it all away in a
couple moves this is awful for Mickey
truly it is but look at what that could
mean it means for Wesley so that he will
he'll I believe that will uh Propel him
to the 2800 Club on the live ratings ABS
one of 12 players in the history ever
crossed 2800 in the history of Chess wow
and what a but he's earned it I mean
even game you know with these you feel
that there's an advantage with double
Bishop B to convert it like this and uh
brilliant win and that means two losses
for Mickey it's going to be a tough
tournament to come back from and what is
start Wesley has had but going back to
our game of kwana I mean this position
is just incredibly captivating I mean
there are so many tactical possibilities
here going on and let's get an update to
what the players got up to uh after
after uh the the human move Queen D2 not
The Rook E8 variation that we're looking
at was played and after Queen takes E1
Fabby with a minute on his clock against
10 minutes of vesselin and that's not so
accurate played D4 still six moves to go
yasa and it's uh it's a very tough
situation but I have to say that it has
liquidated a bit I mean a few moves ago
it would have been a lot more tougher
but now I feel uh black has still got it
a bit under control Alejandro does he it
seems like his position is okay at least
the pawn on G7 is powerful but because
of the weakness of the King on F1 and
the power of the Pawn on D3 there's
nothing white can really do about it
there have the Knight on B1 here is just
too far out of place still it's been the
curse for white ever since he put
underneath three early in the opening
here he has this position where topalov
is also kind of running out of time he
doesn't have an infinite amount of time
Karana is the one that's in heavy time
pressure but hey the rest also has to
find correct continuations here there's
obviously the threat of taking on C3 and
then pushing the pawn you have to really
do something here on the queen side
compter suggesting to Simply take the
pawn on D4 but here Knight takes D4 it
seems that white is still surviving he
can either put the Knight on D2 he can
also go G4 with the idea of giving the
king a loft and the computer start
saying holding on because the pawn on G7
is still quite powerful but it's
immensely complicated and so easy to go
wrong in this position uh Alejandra C3
takes D4 for me I wouldn't want to
invite the Knight to the party uh if I
were in white shoes and it was a Blitz
game I would play C3 C4 with the hope
for idea of blockading on
D2 and we are just very quickly going to
update you with the Wesley so game as
whoa something has just happened
happened uh the Arbiter has asked Mickey
I believe to update his score sheet he
must have forgotten uh move Bishop E5
caused him to forget to update a scor
sheet that's what I think is being
discussed on the
webcam well no I think he ran out of
time oops I apologize few more seconds
on this clock but but well he anyways
resigned because it was
it's definitely white King on the
winning square right uh and Wesley so
two Z and I believe start
2800 I mean we just have to recognize
what a great achievement it is for this
young man Unstoppable he seems
Unstoppable right now I mean even though
you might say that yesterday's game he
got gifted a point but this was he
earned it was such a masterpiece yes
yeah and Mickey Adams usually is very
very tough in those positions and
holding it but let me come back to you
again Alejandro uh I was going to
suggest C4 yeah C4 loses but we're C4
loses just like that we're going to be
worried about that later but C4 still
looks more logical than the move to pile
of play that I have no idea how he even
came up with it he played Knight D2 what
is that what inviting D what inviting D
takes
C3 and I mean he's just what is KN
D2 which happened I know that's why I'm
updating oh he's got the idea of Knight
C4 perhaps and knight4 and I think he
missed he missed this move Knight C4
seems like it's winning for white
because you have Queen e3 coming yes he
missed this
move that's an easy move to missor easy
move to miss that is Sao hasn't made it
yet the big question is is he going to
find it it's the only move now it's
completely winning after Knight takes B2
Rook takes E1 King takes E1 Pawn takes
B2 you cannot stop this Pawn if you
capture The Rook here after Rook E8 you
have Queen C1 check not made yet but you
have D2 right and now that's completely
winning F has found rookie the game is
basically over it is completely losing
for topalo must have completely Overlook
the move
rookie right and especially when your
opponent is time and in time trouble
that he finds that he finds that move
Rook E8 that's it's completely done
there's not even a chance of maybe
making the getting complicated for the
last few seconds that Fabiano does have
it's very simple now that he found
rookie 8 the pawns push forward and
that's game over wow a winning move and
a spectacular winning move that's such
an easy move to miss yes I have to say
it is exactly because of this problem
that Fabiano was in time trouble that I
felt that at some point bestland started
playing against the time rather than the
position and making some moves fast
faster than he should have he messed up
a huge
advantage and yeah rookie and it's game
over now yes it is Rook e 8 but again
this is the position just exploded after
this move night D2 very very tactical
position if you don't mind explaining to
me uh uh Alejandro I thought after the
move d4
C4 uh you know just to stop what
happened in the game D4 takes C3 why
would that have lost Knight E5 that's
correct Knight E5 in this position is
winning for black
that's just too many pieces coming in
Knight take C4 is coming in the next
move and I'm threatening D2 obviously
you cannot take on E5 as I'm simply
taking on B1 and you're attacking The
Rook that's the Ah that's it very good
thank you yeah another blind spot still
better than Knight D2 still better than
KN I have to say it's amazing the kind
of moves that Fabiano has found in his
time travel and we do have a result in
giri versus Hikaru they have agreed for
a drop very interesting so that was
uh not very surprising considering that
they've had 22 draws in their previous
and there's V looking at the ruins of a
very good position and the thing is he
can even Queen he actually isn't going
to be losing a queen in most variations
I mean you can probably take on B2 take
on E1 King takes E1 and you get a queen
on G8 the problem is the weakness of the
king at the end so uh takes on B2 takes
on E1 takes on E1 look at how many
queens are suddenly about to appear in
the position
uh oh uh my my board froze the moment I
played G8 oh we still have a that bug
yeah we've got that little bug uh a
graphic comes on and he asks me what
piece I'd like to promote to and
sometimes it doesn't come on and maybe
on your side you'll have to show it
all let's let's let's try not to uh not
to freeze both of the boards I do have a
Queen by the way uh oh I got it oh very
good it works on mine Queen and we have
this position the problem is that the
weakness of the king is just way too way
too much here check on C2 King
E3 check on E2 King F4 and at some point
I just go D2 you don't have
anything uh to do about it it's just
completely losing and we have Maurice
Ashley with our current tournament
leader a perfect two out of two Wesley
so and an absolutely historic moment for
Wesley Soul fans first of all he's now
number four player in the world that is
a personal High he's also over 2,800 for
the first time ever joining a very elite
club of players at the 2800 level Wesley
you must be very satisfied with this
result today yeah definitely better than
what I expected you know I went for this
quiet line but unfortunately he started
to make some mistakes and then in the
end here on real low on time which is
surprising because he had more time uh
around the middle but yeah very
satisfying win you in another game
tomorrow you saw when this game was
going on it looked like it was solid for
him some of the commentators were saying
no way black loses this position but it
seemed like there was always a little
bit of fire in the position yeah no I
think no way for anyone to lose his too
much to to make too much a statement but
at the same time uh black indeed has a
very solid position but I had the bishop
there which I was very satisfied about
and I also play basically Pawn up in the
king side for Pawn versus three and of
course I could have won without the help
of my of his mistakes but at the same
time I believe uh white out small chance
all throughout you're 2 and0 you're
leading the tournament you're leading
the grand chest tour uh and and you have
all these accomplishments all in one day
tell us what that feels like real
amazing real amazing uh feeling now to
have all the hard work and Sacrifice by
me and my family to pay off uh but at
the same time I'll be playing two blacks
in my next two games games so I have to
be really careful uh against the the
dangerous opponents
um but uh yeah yeah hopefully I can look
back after cmon's over and say that the
good start helped me finish well well
congratulations so we certainly proud of
seeing you play this great chess and
good luck in the rest of your games
thank you Grandmaster Wesley so leading
the tournament in clear first but also
guys only 11 players before him had
broken the 2800 mark he has joined an
elite club of 2800 players a fantastic
moment for this young gentleman to my
right congratulations Wesley what a
brilliant achievement absolutely
deserved and we do have a result on the
Topo Fabiano game Topo has resigned
speaking of high rated American Players
let's just take a quick look at that
finish after Rook E8 toala in
desperation play the move Rook takes B7
actually taking with the King also works
it's not a problem but taking with the
queen is probably the most precise
Queen takes E8 and after Queen B1 check
talo resigned the problem for him being
that after Queen E1 C2 even though I
promote first black is promoting with
Checkmate on C1 the game is completely
done topalo had to resign heartbreaking
because he had a winning position at
some point not only that he had a huge
time Advantage Fabby basically not only
saved the game managed to turn it around
with his beautiful rookie eight shot
that topalo must have completely
overlooked what an absolute up down game
that was hindsight being perfect uh we
now recognize at this position what a
really catastrophic mistake this move
Rook E6 was not paying enough attention
to this power of the Pawn on D3 it
turned out that that in fact won the
game for black the move Queen G6 is
suggested by Alejandra much earlier
eliminating that uh D3 Pawn was probably
the road to Victory and what a narrow
path it was no absolutely but I think
this gets us to the point that in chess
so often when our opponent is in a time
in in time trouble we start playing
quickly to make advantage of that so
you're actually playing against your
against the time and not the opponent in
the position and that's never a good
idea because we see that things like
these happen then well I must say to uh
fabby's credit when opportunity knocked
he he came out with some really uh super
moves this move D3 D5 D4 it's really
really easy to underestimate the power
of that at this exact moment I still
thought oh White's doing fine I mean his
Pawn on G7 is far more dangerous than
this Pawn on D2 Knight D2 not the case
not the case so dangerous I mean if DC3
you've got to calculate this move
completely because you're just allowing
two pawns on on the third rank even a
move like G3 you know just that was
important actually the white king ended
up being the one that was really under a
lot of threat at and uh G3 might have
been a better resource than what was
played does that uh complete Our Round
by the way yes that's it and we've got
three decisive results today as well
spoiled we'll take us through with the
we'll get the results but two Z we know
who's our tournament leader vesley who's
been having a fantastic door and has got
three players in second that's right
well we're going to be having the
standings up shortly but I mean this
game what a game we've had turn and
let's take a look at the current
standings so our big tournament leader
is Wesley so two points beating uh
Mickey Adams today in a very nice game
Vish Anand also played some brilliant
chess took some practical decisions
which paid off in the end showing a
really typical pattern of sacrificing
the bishop and creating an a pass Pawn
in the end which could not be stopped
faban Carana I've got to say got
extremely lucky between Kos to him to
actually find resources when he was down
to seconds exactly and uh Vladimir
kramnik is on one and a half he drew his
game today Anish giri on a point he drew
with Hikaru as well so uh yes what a day
we've had and vesselin super unlucky
today as well and he's still on zero
points still at the bottom of the board
with Mickey Adams they're still to and
what a tournament we've had point out
that Anish gear is the only person at
50% yes two draws the only person with
two draws that's true and and 50% yeah
mhm mvl uh andaru are both at at Half
Point yes wow well again some other uh
little dramas going on one of them is of
course that Fabiana kijana within
Striking Distance of world's number one
Magnus Carlson we were talking that he
needs a big result he got a huge result
today he was gambling uh gambling a bit
but it paid off it paid off and I think
he he found some excellent resources in
time trouble and vesin was just not able
to handle it well let's go to London cuz
we've got Karana with
Maurice well we have one American Wesley
so on 2 and0 and another one at one and
a half now plus one grandm Fabiano
Carana after what really is a miraculous
comeback fabbi you started off the game
at some point you looked okay and right
around now you seem to start drifting
and it looked all R like you were going
to get killed this game yeah I um I
thought that my position was good around
this point or a few M before um but it's
so complicated it's I mean white has a
has Jeep on which I'm never getting rid
of and my compensation is basically the
night on A3 um and yeah later I felt
like I was losing I also had um excuse
me very little time but I mean right
here the engine's saying you're better
but after this move uh this move pushing
and then especially here right around
now you started to drift a bit and and
King A7 was this just what was the
purpose behind the move King A7 well the
idea is that it avoids back rang stuff
and after Bishop C5 maybe there there no
checks on this diagonal um but Knight D3
was was just a bad move so right here
you play the move Knight D3 that was an
awful move I can't yeah suddenly you
were in a lot of trouble did you feel
the trouble right around now did you did
you
should be basically lost um okay I
thought that it's very unclear anyway
because the night1 A3 is still misplaced
and I do have a pass Pawn which is hard
to get rid of um but I didn't see what
I'm doing and I thought rookie 6 was
already a big step in the wrong
direction now after C8 there's always a
lot of back rank tricks um Queen G5 is
probably also not a good move I think
Bishop D4 is maybe maybe not even the
only move but
I the the engines here I think it was
Queen D5
was trying trying to figure out after
Bishop C3 bc3 rook d8 and I I mean it's
possible for either side to lose just
with one mistake what were you thinking
right now your clock was terrible I mean
you were really starting to take down
were you just playing on Instinct what
do you do in a situation like this when
there's just not much time to think I
was just trying I was trying to take the
time that he was thinking to calculate
any variations um but every move he
played surprised me Rook E6 Queen G5 and
Rook e one were all uh all not moves I
had even considered um but I think I
managed to at least not blunder anything
and then after um so right here the game
changed dramatically move now yes so
this move was possible as well Rook G7
with the idea of Rook h8 that one oh
that's came out of nowhere that is
brutal and King J Bish too yeah that um
that was that's a computer move for sure
yeah nobody nobody else noticed this the
computer of course so you played more
logically with this move and now it was
in this position that he played
here and you're back in the game when
did you see from you played very quickly
and played the move D when I saw D4 I
thought it was okay I was expecting C
takes D4 here um and then I was going to
play Knight D4 with a nice trick if
Knight D2 I let's play that out C D4
Knight D4 Knight D2 I thought it was a
logical move and Rook Rook C8 is good
but I thought Rook G7 I thought this was
a nice little trap because Rook G7
Knight C2 and don't like what you did
for some reason Rook B7 I saw Queen wild
check Queen B7 on Queen E5 for some
reason I thought my position was good
here um and there's no check down here
and it looks as though white is white is
okay lucky for you you didn't have to
play this yeah I I mean it's in time
trouble I would probably um screw it up
very quickly all right well this did not
happen after D4 now tell us right here
you took he played Knight D2 did you
realize Rook E8 was coming in this
position um I mean I assumed after DC3
he would play Knight C4 because Queen E3
Queen B6 and I saw Rook E8 um so you had
seen it by now yeah I mean I don't know
if it's the only move I could also play
Queen B4 Queen E3 King B8 and there's no
Rook of eight check but I assume it's a
Perpetual there and rookie a just wins
on the spot how did he respond I wasn't
in the room he played Rook to E8 did he
did you see a physical reaction from him
when this move landed on the board he
looked surprised at first um and then he
looked unhappy oh so he did he did react
emotionally well a great win for you I
mean it's a great save at least what are
your feelings now moving forward in the
tournament
I mean I got lucky today um and I can't
say I played the first two games
exceptionally well but the result is
still good I can't complain at all and
your thoughts on your compatriot Wesley
so you've you've been watching him all
year long you saw how great he played
next to you uh in the Olympiad as a
teammate you guys won together and now
this are you surprised by how well he's
playing or how well his his results are
stacking up yeah he um something must
have clicked for him because he's
improved a lot at least in terms of
results recently um and he rarely puts
himself in any danger he's um he's a
very consistent player um he doesn't go
on Rampages or anything but he usually
just quietly accumulates points and if
his opponents um do I mean self-destruct
as we saw in the first round then then
he gladly takes the point indeed well
congratulations on your results and good
luck in the rest of your games Grand
Master Fabiano Carana TI for second
place hey luck counts in chess we'll
take those points it absolutely does
thank you Maurice and the luckless
vessel and topof because oh this this is
a real setback this is really really
tough he was weighing very well to a
point and then it just all went wrong
right yes and going back to that point
of Rook h8 I have no doubts that the
only reason Fabiano was not able to find
that was because he was shot on time I
mean these guys were it's a gorgeous
tactic way but I am sure that the reason
that wasn't on board was only because
they've got such less time right I think
it was exactly here this one one moment
where you get to go Rook takes G7
eliminating this very powerful pass Pawn
Rook takes G7 and then suddenly Rook h8
a move that you never really thinking
about because the pawn on G7 controls
the h8 square and suddenly there's no
way
handling this and Fabby immediately said
oh I see King G1 Bishop F2 resigns and
that would have been an amazing tactic
but even the one that we got on the
board with rookie I mean that was also
very very beautiful just finishing the
game on the spot extremely unlucky for
velin but he did mess up a very very
good position yes let's get some final
insights from Maurice in London
well the place is simply a buzz the fans
getting their money's worth for this
tournament yesterday we saw three wins
today we saw three wins extremely
exciting chess going on here at the
London chess classic uh just incredible
watching Wesley so the star Rising now
over
2800 joining an elite club what will
happen next in the next rounds well you
don't want to miss it and we will be
giving you all the blowby blow here from
London
we thinking about the 20 100 I'm
thinking to myself I'm laughing to
myself but I think the tpr has to be
close to
3,800 at this exact moment uh what do
you think uh Alejandro 3,800 uh tpr
after two games I know it's a joke but
yeah the tpr breaks on the tournament
performance rating breaks when there's
100% score you actually cannot calculate
it but I mean Wesley he's just playing
good chess his opponents are crumbling
un Under Pressure that he's putting on
Adams he never fully equalized I mean
you can't say that Wesley got lucky that
Adams blundered he was just under
pressure under pressure under pressure
and in time pressure he cracked and
that's what happened I mean Wesley was
just better the entire game and
sometimes this happens but what a round
we had today I mean let's go through it
kramnick aonian Bishop takes G2
sharpening the position out of nowhere
that was fantastic Maxim v l gra what a
game from the opening just vishy
throwing those pawns forward excellent
preparation and the final shot Bishop
takes p7 you know that's going to go in
the book we already talked about Wesley
pushing with a pair of Bishops topalo
with Zig wow what a game here we had I
mean yes we didn't get the Rook takes G7
shot but we got Rook E8 that's almost as
good and well the final game wasar
Nakamura finally stabilizing a little
bit and defending a slightly worse
position against Anish giri for a while
I mean what a round we had a great start
here in the first two games in London
and I can only hope that it continues
this way absolutely decisive results I
love it spoiled I do I feel
spoiled I was just about to say uh
before we go off the air do we know
who's playing who tomorrow do we have
the pairings or we'll we'll do that
tomorrow let's take a look at the
matchups for tomorrow what do we have in
store Tanya so we've got Leon aronian up
against the tournament leader veso who
is so in form right now uh we've got
Michael Adams who's had a terrible start
playing Anish giri the super solid Anish
who drew with Hikaru today in probably a
slightly better position out of the
opening but nothing much Hikaru Nakamura
is up against vishi an and I've got to
say that wishi is also seeming like the
Tiger on the board that he is and Maxim
is who had a really tough game against
Wishy today and what an end we saw on
that is up against Westland so both
these players are definitely looking to
bounce back into the tournament fa that
last number two versus number three
three in the world so we've got two
2800s a face off tomorrow between
Fabiano karwana and Vladimir
KCK and live
ratings besto is at
2803 so he has he is the 12th player to
make his tree by crossing the 2800 and
the first Asian player uh well actually
vishy is the first Asian player over
2800 the first Philippine player what a
what an extraordinary accomplishment
really a great have to hat tip to Wesley
bravo bravo bravo absolutely well we are
going to be back tomorrow because London
chess classic is just getting exciting
by the day so see you tomorrow same
time
[Music]
[Applause]